e
e e
come to order members take your seats
chair recognizes a member from Auburn
represent Auburn who moves at the house
adjourned from the session of May 30th
2024 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those suppose nay
the eyes have
it house will attend to a Prayer by
house chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart
pastor of St Paul's United Methodist
Church in
Manchester well before we start our
prayer how about those Celtics
keep praying we got one more to
go good morning Mr Speaker good morning
House of
Representatives let us be in a unified
Spirit of
prayer good morning
God thank you for this beautiful and
glorious
day oh gracious God in this world full
of noise and unrest help us to find your
peace and
calm in this world when we feel lost or
lonely help and guide us to find you our
Compass oh loving God in this world full
of hate and
rage help us to feel and
experience your
love in this world full of of loneliness
help us to find
Community with each
other and in this world full of
hopelessness and
emptiness help us to find you the source
of all good
things on this final session day of this
New Hampshire House of
Representatives God I come again asking
that you bless each member and leader
for this great state of New Hampshire
place your hands upon each one as they
make decisions of all
legislation that is presented before
them
today help each of us to listen
carefully and to respect each other for
what we have in
common the commonality we
share is we are all children of
God as we prepare for our summer
break may it be a safe and healthy time
away for each member and
leader may we all enjoy the beauty of
the world you have created for us and
enjoy some rest and relaxation from all
business matters until we meet
again we ask this oh God in your holy
name
amen I want to personally
thank Bob for being our pastor for the
past few years this will be Bob's last
time uh addressing us he's moving
on
but he's been my pastor for a while and
I want to give him my personal thanks
but let's give him a hearty W hearty
thank you for my body
[Applause]
Jer recognizes a member from Kent
representative M Meer who will lead us
in Poli
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the rep for it
stands one nation God indivisible with
liy and justice for all
the chair recognizes the new Middle High
School chorus from Milton who will now
sing our national
anthem for
[Music]
for
FL
[Music]
the
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of
absence Mr speaker the day illness
Representatives fedus Katherine Harvey
and trevan the day important business
Representatives ktoa Mason O'Hara
sandborn Traer and
true these absence will be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the
house house will attend to the
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome members of the wolfboro Senior
Citizen Center guests of Representatives
McDonald cordelli and pno Owen and Nancy
coffee guests of Representative Lily
Walsh David and Carolyn Smith guests of
Representative NAB Cindy nutting mother
of Representative nutting Pete mahagan
guest of Representative Dan Maguire
Santos salvi guest of Representative
Darby Sher reinford and Henry gon guests
of Representative Missour Diane and
Jason Miler and Marcy Myer plant family
of Representative Myer Sebastian Fuentes
Gail Bailey and Sebastian and Pila
Fuentes guests of Representative Cel
Donna Jacob Natalie and Amelia sers and
Meredith pagee wife grandchildren and
stepdaughter of Representative sers The
Honorable Lisa Freeman former member
from Manchester guest of representative
Harvey bolia The Honorable Dan itsa
former member from Fremont guest of
Representatives Hobson Bernard and Hull
The Honorable Manny espia former member
from NASA and Mato espia guests of
Representative Laura cherski in the h
David Welch former member from Kingston
guest of Representative shirtliff they
are with us in the gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire
[Applause]
[Music]
house the house will attend to Memorial
remarks for former members The Honorable
David bapson of wase and the honorable
Timothy oconnell of Milford chair
recognizer froment of
bolo the house will be in order
great thank you thank you for joining me
remembering in
Remembering representative David bson
from oapi and representative Tim
mconnell from Milford they both passed
in May within three weeks of each other
they were best of
friends uh both passed in May and served
on environment and agriculture Committee
in the mid 2000s serving at least years
as the chair and vice chair of
environment and agriculture my first
four years back in the in the 2000s I
was on the ENA committee serving as
their clerk very they were very witty
intellects David bapson was born in
1938 went to Wesley Hills um high school
he was a class of
1961 at Brown University he was a
Collegiate athlete who excelled at both
hockey and Lacrosse he served in the
naval reserves and started his own
company
mni at steel fabrication in 1979 he
moved to oapi and raised oxen milking
cows trained draft horses he leveraged
his agricultural expertise by serving
his um uh his constituents for over 20
years first as a New Hampshire State
Legislature in the early 2000s chair of
an with representative Tim oconnell
David's creativity knew no bounds as
seen in his work in his wood carving
needle point and knitting he was an
active member of the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau and his um commemoration of life
will be held on August 4th at 1:00 at
the remik Museum and farm in Tamworth
Tim mconnell from
Milford
um moved to Peterboro during his last
two years he died at age 80 and bapson
died at age 78 Tim graduated from
University of Bridgeport with a Bachelor
of Science degree in biology and a
master of science degree in education he
earned another Masters of Science in
environmental science from forom
University Tim married Norine in 1965
the couple loved farming on Federal Hill
in Milford and successfully harvesting
successfully harvesting vegetables
flowers Christmas trees and they raised
goats um at Butternut Farm in Milford
Tim taught biology at Milford High
School for over
25 years Tim was New Hampshire state
representative from 1998 to 2008 Vice
chair of EV Ena with David bson he was
instrumental in developing the farmers
markets in Milford nashwa Manchester and
Bedford he farmed until 2022
Tim was a magnet to all animals big and
small and could I um say a few words
regarding um Representative Bob Smith
from Manchester he just passed a couple
days ago and there's there's another
good friend of mine um Bob R who passed
a few days ago he was in New Hampshire
State Rep from Manchester for eight
years from 1964 to
1972 minority leader in 1968 Democratic
candidate for governor in
1972 United States Marshall for the
State of New Hampshire appointed by
President Jimmy Carter and at the same
time he was a full-time student at
Franklin Pierce Law Center admitted to
the bar in 1980 honorary counil to FR
France early advocate for gay rights
notwithstanding his devout CA
Catholicism Bob dearly loved his wife
Mary he always said that he was the
luest man in the world to have married
her Bob leaves behind five children
several grandchildren and great
grandchildren Bob was one of my father's
best friends June 17th his memorial
service is June 17th at 10:30 um at St
Katherine's Church in Manchester thank
you for the
time please rise for a moment of silence
for the honorable David Babson and
honorable Timothy MCC
chair recognizes the clerk for a motion
to suspend house
rules Mr
Speaker representative Kush man moves
that house rules be so far suspended to
allow for the creation of a special
investigative committee to investigate
the division for children youth and
families the Family Division of the
circuit court and any persons or
entities said committee deems necessary
in determining
maladministration further that the
committee shall consist of 20 members
appointed by the house having full
powers of Investigation including
collection of sworn testimony and the
issuance of subpoenas said committee to
issue a report of findings to the house
by November 1st 2024 with any
recommendations including whether to
recommend articles of impeachment for
the next session of the House of
Representatives CH recogniz represent
kushman to speak to a
motion thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning
colleagues this motion to suspend the
rules is so that the house rather than
the speaker May appoint a special
investigative committee with full powers
of Investigation as delineated in
Mason's manual including the ability to
obtain sworn testimony and subpoena
documents and Witnesses for
Testimony why do we need this committee
we have two already actually we have
four actually we've had a lot more of
than that over the last 20 years and yet
year after year more victims of these
systems are created and show up at our
legislative hearings telling us that
they are being harmed by these systems
this very inter related closely
woven systems of child welfare in this
state that includes the family court and
DCF and some contractors and other
agencies there
are serious issues that need to be
gotten to the bottom of we need actual
investigation these committees that
exist this year the two special
committees one on family court and one
on DC
ifif have started some great work
they've laid some good
groundwork they've collected
testimony
and and they've dug in a little bit into
the issues at play but there are
pressures that are preventing them from
digging too
deeply
and if those house creates a committee
those pressures go
away if you read my email you know that
no one from DCF has appeared before the
special committee on
DCF despite the friendly invitations
from the
chair and additionally only one judge
from the family court the administrative
judge has appeared before the special
committee on Family Court there are
questions that need to be pursued there
are allegations that need to be probed
there are concerns that need to be
deeply investigated
this special committee that we're
talking about forming now will have the
full Authority and investigative power
to do what needs to be done should the
House vote in favor the committee will
be
authorized to answer those
questions this is not McCarthy we have
specific
names of people
within these branches of government and
agencies that that have been the subject
of repeated
complaints and over the years the
victims come to the Committees and say
we have a problem and the committee say
that is terrible thank you for letting
us know we'll try to write a
bill and hope that we can change it for
the next people who go through the
system I think we've lost a little bit
of understanding that our main job our
first job is to redress grievance when
the rights of the people
are being
trespassed we swore oath to that that we
will do that and from time to time pass
bills as may be necessary for the common
good so the committee will work to
thoroughly investigate allegations of
misconduct conflicts of interest
maladministration violations of due
process that we know from testimony in
those other committees already exist
violations of court orders perjury and
coverup that have been heard in
committee hearings in this body for 20
years or
more why is it
needed sununu Youth Detention Center
self-explanatory need I say more on that
well I will will it bankrupt the state
when the lawsuit damn breaks are the
problematic players still seated in
office or
employment $38
million awarded to one victim despite
this body trying to prevent payouts more
than 475,000
we cannot legislate the state out of
liability for this we can prevent
further abuses from like this from
happening if we take Swift decisive
action not only with legislation but we
need to investigate and hold accountable
when we find that those inves tigations
lead to certain
people over and over again or certain
processes over and over again we've
already have around 240 cases for the
sununu center YDC case um as of May with
1400 victims in total so do the
math
um there are allegations of conflicts of
interest in handling investigations
between the state and private
contractors and just looking at who
those players are it's obvious that does
need to be looked into you've got the AG
you've got law firms and the Coalition
against Domestic and Sexual Violence
playing both sides at different points
over the years one on the side of the
victims other times on the side of the
state it's a little convoluted and it
needs
probing without the house having the
ability to effectuate our power we're
probably never going to get a real
investigation on that as of May 16th the
state has awarded $66 million through
the settlement fund and those
represented by other claimants are
getting higher s
settlements
um do you want to keep up racking up
more of those
cases how big is our state
budget we're talking billions
potentially
why is this committee needed the people
have brought testimony repeatedly
alleging the following issues in family
court that a Judicial retreat in the
1990s resulted in a group of Judges
planning to run Family Court as a
business that judges in there are not
judges but Federal contractors they're
called surrogate judges their orders are
recommendations and not enforcable
unless signed by a judge who and they
have testified judges actual judges have
sign testified before the house that
they can't sign off on orders over wi
cases which they didn't preside so are
the orders from Family Court even
enforceable Family Court fails to
protect children again these are
allegations there have been deaths of
children and kidnappings directly
related to the failures of Family
Court it depends on which court and
which judge you have whether you get
Fair
process decision-making is arbitrary
some courts make findings of abuse in
100% of cases such as Keen in 2023 and
others make findings of abuse in 0% of
cases such as brentw Brentwood and marac
in 2023 that is worth a closer look the
findings of abuse that occur in Family
Court follow uh that the F that occur in
Family Court follow statute that
sidesteps constitutional due process
part one Article 15 requires a trial by
jury before your Liberty interests are
taken from you your children are the
oldest Liberty interests and your dear
having your children taken from you is
akin to Capital
Punishment yet there is no trial by jury
option you can appeal to the superior
court but anything that's ruled judicial
discretion is not sub
admissible and most things are ruled
judicial
discretion there are failures of the
court to make appropriate referrals and
address crime and criminal activity is
child abuse a crime
why are there no criminal
charges by failing to make
referrals um they're perpetuating
criminal activity and
abuse a 1990 uh sorry family court is
operated by private
contractors they all know each other
I've heard the phrase Court Country Club
more than
once private contractors that work in
the Family Court are not limited or
accountable for unregulated billing
they're granted full immunity for the
work they
do they work collaboratively with each
other sometimes not in the best
interests of the litigants or the
children contributing to bias in the
court rules of evidence are not strictly
adhered to and can be applied
arbitrarily and how they're applied can
determine the outcome of a case in some
cases they'll accept evidence from one
party and none from the
other transcripts often have
inaccuracies and alter options from what
actually was said in court failure of
the court to comply with Federal
requirements to hold child support
hearings before obtaining child support
orders causing homelessness for litigant
through orders separating families
without evidence failure to to disclose
and gain
consent children ordered into
unnecessary Services parents ordered
into unnecessary services that they all
have to pay for we're talking tens of
thousands of dollars
failure to address perjury whether
committed by litigants attorneys or
judges we've got allegations of problems
with G's in Portsmith problems with
judges in Bedford some of those were
confirmed um allegations about Judges
owning owning mediation companies and
having conflicts of interest and
advertising that their mediation
services are for high net worth
clients incentives to protract 20% of
cases to obtain title for money meaning
cases that should be easily dealt with
and in and out of the Court quickly that
aren't high conflict are kept in a state
of conflict and made to come back to
meet that
20% and this is
not these are specific allegations about
specific courts and specific people
specific contractors that I'm speaking
about in generalities this is not to say
that the entirety of the court system is
corrupt and and you know that every
single person is guilty these are these
are complaints that need to be looked
into this again this is not McCarthy
these are specific instances that have
been brought to the attention of this
body and to the court and to the AG in
many C in many instances that just went
nowhere and the people are looking for
redress they're coming to the people's
Branch for it
DCF 117 child deaths directly linked to
DC CF since
2018 I'll say that again the office of
the child advocate came into existence
in 2018 and yes since it was formed it
has found 117 children have died who had
DCF involved in their
lives DCF is not protecting
children there are allegations that some
agents have covered up their mistakes
and in order to do so they left children
to be further abused and in order to
protect themselves failure on the part
of DCF work DCF workers to inform people
of their rights workers perjuring
themselves in court motions without
consequence dcyf employees telling the
family court that a child should be
reunified with a stepfather who is being
investigated for sexual abuse of three
of the children in the
home criminal charges for child sex
abuse image charges and had bail
conditions not to be around the children
and protective orders and dcyf went and
told the family court that that home is
safe and the children would benefit from
being
there the state refuses to settle on
cases where the petitioner seeks
employee
termination there is one specific worker
at DCF who is named in many of the
lawsuits and is still working and is
still on the
cases that the lawsuits are
about there are DCF DCF workers alleged
um that a father sexually abused his
children when those same workers knew
the daycare that the children attended
was being investigated for child sex
abuse
crimes and did not disclose that
DCF has been alleged of hiding
exculpatory evidence and refusing to
hand it over to the family court Court
they've made findings of abuse in closed
hearings without the option for the
accused to appear face their accuser
offer evidence of their innocence or
view evidence against them those
findings put their name on a nationwide
registry limiting their career and
custody opportunities and often are
rubber stamps stamped by the family
court as
true allegations that depr that DCF
regularly deprives substantive due
process and procedural due process
process they failed to provide
court-ordered physician recommended
School recommended and psychiatrist
recommended Therapy Services for
children in their
care there are allegations of problems
with the District Attorney's offices in
dealing with these complaints about DCF
and the family court as
well there's allegations of
collaboration between DCF and police in
pursuing charges against parents say
retaliation for disagreement with dcyf
these are serious allegations I hope
they're not true I we need to stay
skeptical we need to approach this with
a
balanced um you know standpoint of
examination but these things do need to
be examined they are worth pursuing and
having a true investigation about I just
spoke with a mom in the hallway who I've
never met before who told me yet another
horror story about her kids and she's
sitting in the
gallery she hasn't seen her son in over
400 Days he was taken from her in an exp
parte she claims her husband was abusing
her and there was a finding of abuse by
DCF that the the family court ignored
and in an Exar motion overturned that
allegation and granted custody to him
and said that she was manipulating the
child and there may be truth to
that but they're coming to us for a
reason because they're not getting
further redress
elsewhere so this is our job we're the
people's Branch we have the power of
Investigation we don't utilize it often
we we seem to have a an idea that you
know everyone who works in our state
government has good intentions but we
need to bear in mind that people with
ulterior motives and predatory behavior
seek out positions where they have
access to people they wish to exploit
and predate
predate so we can't protect
them just in order to protect the good
workers
too we need to look into these
complaints and take them
seriously how are we going to chase down
all these rabbit Trails one at a time we
look into the complaint collect the
testimony subpoena Witnesses documents
if necessary what do you have have to
say about these allegations against you
or your department or your your employee
did you know about this find the
history if we find common threads pursue
it we're looking at policy of course but
there are more than policy issues here
and the other two committees don't have
the tools at their disposal because of
house rules and improper influence RSA
6:30 640 col
3 this motion allows the body to move
around the improper influence and give
the committee all the tools it needs to
do this work for the people thank you I
hope you'll support
it question is on the motion to suspend
house rules are you ready for the
question roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote e
to
you want a parliamentary inquiry
house will be in order the motion before
us is to suspend the
rules this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes Representative Steven Smith
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this has never
been done in the history of the house
and that even if I were inclined to
support it it would be better to ask me
that question on day one of a session so
it could be monitored evaluated and
adjusted as it needed and not as we're
literally headed out the door and Mr
Speaker if I also know that it's
unnecessary because if there are indeed
specific allegations against specific
people State officials any member is
free to file a house resolution for
articles of impeachment and that no one
has done that then Mr Speaker would I
defeat this unnecessary and potentially
Reckless motion by pressing the red
button the motion before us is to
suspend the rules this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent the Lo
all members president have an
opportunity to
vote all members present had the
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state of the
vote 120 voting a 247 voting a motion
fails chair recognizes the Clark Mr
Speaker
what for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion print the remarks of
the um previous activity please perment
journal without objection
we had an OB we've had an objection you
have all right there has been an
objection this will be a vote to whether
we print the remarks and division has
been
requested a roll call has been requested
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote e
the motion before us is to print the
remarks on the previous
debate this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognized represent vervo
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mi Mr Speaker if if
I know that there's a very small nominal
cost to to print remarks in the
permanent journal and Mr Speaker if I
know we routinely print uh remarks of
all different Natures into the permanent
journal and Mr Speaker if I know that
this topic addresses a very serious
issue that's not just facing our state
now but has been for
decades and Mr Speaker if I believe that
there's some value in allowing those
remarks to be read by the general
population our citizens our constituents
down the road so that they can
understand what the motion was about and
that this body was at least taking the
time to give it serious
consideration but I now press the green
button to print the remarks in the
permanent Journal knowing that no
specific names were given no reputations
are hurt and and there is no downside to
printing these remarks please press the
green button thank you Mr Speaker the
motion before us is to print the remarks
of the previous debate this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're poll
you press the red button boning stations
we open for 30 seconds
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay the
vote 248 vo8 120 voting a the remarks
will chair recognizes the
clerk for a committee conference reports
Mr Speaker House Bill
266 relative to administration of school
assessment and accountability programs
by the Department of Education
represent representative lad moves we
adopt the committee of conference report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I I suppose nay the eyes
have it report is
adopted representative Osborne
moves the consent calendar on the
committee of conference reports for
Senate
bills are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I those oppose nay
the eyes have it consent calendar
adopted further
report Mr Speaker Senate Bill 340
relative to communication between
parents and school districts regarding
special education special education
reporting requirements and the office of
the advocate for special
education representative lad moves we
adopt the report and we do have a debate
on this one chair recognizes
representative B bony
thank you Mr
Speaker s SP 340 as introduced was a
simple Bill to allow when notices and
Records regarding a child's IEP to be
distributed to the parent electronically
with parental
consent that was supported by the house
education committee with a 20 to0 ought
to pass
recommendation a non-main floor
amendment was added and passed by a slim
margin at our house at our house session
on May
23rd this amendment was introduced after
the legislative budget assistant
released the performance audit report of
the special education dispute resolution
process in March a scap in assessment
that determined that the Department of
Education lacked adequate management
controls regulatory framework and a
comprehensive performance measurement
and enforcement
system this is just phase one of the
audit of the special education
department with the full report expected
to be completed this
fall many parents spoke out against the
non-main amendment at the hearing in May
the amendment does not focus on the
major deficiencies identified in the
audit such as mismanagement within the
Department of
Education and effectively maintaining
and tracking student data instead the
amendment seeks to authorize the special
education Advocate more direct access to
Department of Education
databases which the audit has already
determined to be unreliable and
insufficient moreover this access by an
independent party presents not only
concerns with parental consent and the
release of personally identifiable
information but also risks the reporting
of inaccurate
conclusions in fact the role of the
independent
State special education Advocate was
never specifically addressed in the
audit in summary let's not push put the
partially assembled cart before the
horse we should wait for the Department
of Education to work on the required
improvements in data collection first to
assemble a reliable and complete
database then when the final audit of
the department is complete we can use
the suggested recommendations for future
comprehensive legislative action I urge
you to vote against the adoption of the
committee of conference report and press
the red button and Mr Speaker I request
a division
vote J recogniz representative
lad good morning and thank you than you
Mr
Speaker I'd like to not address that
simple part in the the amend uh the
original Bill itself was very simple but
I want to address the amendment which uh
came forward and why it came forward we
received just recently the LBA
performance audit regarding due process
and this is dealing with when a parent
refuses or partially refuses to accept
services or placement of a student with
a dis ability proposed or identified in
an
IEP I don't know if anybody's been
through that process I
have and it's a very difficult process
the first thing you want to do of course
if you're not satisfied for what your
youngster is receiving you go meet with
the teacher the special education
teacher No Satisfaction go to the
principal No Satisfaction there you can
go and appeal to the Department of
Education and request a formal hearing
but this process is extremely
expensive and this is why back in
2022 we introduced legislation that
passed the house passed the Senate was
signed in law creating the independent
Office of the special education Advocate
to assist those parents which have
concerns that the IP is not being
followed or whatever issue the parent
may have my concern was service weren't
being delivered in speech therapy to my
grandson I asked to see the log of the
times the individuals the service
providers had met with my
grandson speech par Pathologists had not
in fact they had a par delivering that
service
occasionally so I was concerned but at
the time I chaired the select board in
the community I was on the zoning board
planning board and in this House
Representatives it would have been
deadly for me to cause this Ruckus
because this went a lot
farther than just Rick lad and my wife
and my
grandson so now that
grandson is doing quite well and I was
opted to have my daughter who is a
speech pathologist deliver the services
at
home and he's very successful right now
majoring in finance as a senior doing a
internship down CNS in Keane but if this
goes to the hearing process and it
doesn't even get settled there it can go
to the court
system and we had testimony from parents
and attorneys that is an extremely
expensive process and most of the cases
are dropped because the parent doesn't
have the wherewithal to pay for these
services
so when we have an issue dealing with
the IEP or a 504 plan and it's
referencing to the services provided
this bill provides a way for that to be
corrected the performance audit listed
observations six observations they say
may require legislative
action we decided we can take action we
just can't wait and kick this can down
the
road talked with I sat in meeting after
meeting with the special education
Advocate the Department of Education and
attorneys representing both sides they
came to mutual agreement on this
bill they agreed we need to take action
now and so we have brought forward a
bill here that deals with requirement
for reporting from the local districts
to the department every September 1 but
most importantly in this Bill we found
out during these discussions that the
records of these students which have
IEPs for example that grandson I had
who's now a senior at St Lawrence
University his records are still in that
database that the department has the
database is
Antiquated and so they're saying wow we
can't let the advocate into this
database because we can't be searching
one record you're going to see all 100
to 200,000 records that in that
database we can't do that because those
people are now mostly adults and furpa
and all that they haven't given
permission for this information to be
released so what this bill did it
created anou that's going to be
developed between the advocate's office
and
doe that will be created allowing The
Advocate to have anou to access that
record but thee will access all that
information and provide it to The
Advocate K office so help can be
provided to these families which are not
sure they and actually they know the
services like mine weren't being
delivered so I encourage you all to
concur on this bill we need it we can't
wait and kick this can down the road we
have people out there needing this
service thank
you B has requested a division this will
be a division vote members take your
seats for
the motion before us to adopt the
committee report on Senate Bill 340 this
is a division vote chair recognized
representative Tanner for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
phase one of the lb's performance audit
of special education dispute resolution
process was just released this March and
if I know this early phase of the audit
identifies many issues within the
special education department that need
to be addressed but most importantly
it's the correction of deficiencies with
maintaining and tracking student data
with a thirdparty v vender or an
appointee like the uh special counsel
that comply with the privacy rules of
furpa and the special education rules of
idea if I know the Department of
Education should make these required
improvements Beyond theou in data
collection as reported in phase one now
to start working with these
recommendations so that the further
comprehensive legislation can address
issues and concerns this fall when the
final report is completed would I now
press the red button to vote no and
reject the committee of conference
report for this untimely and premature
bill which does not focus on or resolve
the major deficiencies identified in
phase one of the audit thank you chair
recognize representative lad for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you if I I know this bill
is not premature if I know that
performance audits legislative
recommendations are necessary to better
assist the Department of Education the
office of special education advocate in
monitoring and tracking the status and
resolution of IEP matters between school
districts and parents if I know without
this legislation The Advocates office
will not have the tools or information
necessary to perform its statutory
responsibilities it basically neuters
that that department if I know and know
and attended numerous meetings involving
the office of special education Advocate
the Department of Education and legal
staff while working together and
arriving at this legislation that will
improve and strengthen the due process
process due resolution process would I
then support the first step in
addressing the LBA performance audit by
pressing the green button thank
you the motion be for us is to concur on
Senate Bill 340 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent
Peterson repres
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 188 voting a 179 voting a
concurrence is
adopted T today we're going to be saying
goodbye to a lot of our
colleagues and some have been here a
number of
times um so as a goodbye presid I'm I'm
going to let former speaker shirtliff go
through a couple of
[Applause]
bills alsoo come to order
the chair recognizes the clerk for a
report Mr Speaker Senate Bill 407
establishing a ground ambulance cost
reporting program and a study by an
independent Actuarial and accounting
expert of the cost of providing ground
sub ambulance services in the
state the question before the house is
the adoption of the represent
representative hunt moves that we adopt
the motion to adopt the committee report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I oppose
nay the eyes have it and the report is
adopted the chair recognizes the clerk
Mr Speaker Senate Bill 417 relative to
out of home placements for
children represent Mark Pearson
recommends that we adopt the committee
report are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I oppose nay
the eyes have it the report is adopted
chair recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker
Senate Bill 480 relative to the
regulation of real estate practice
represent the
adoption representative groer recommends
the adoption of the report are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I oppose
nay the eyes have it the report is
adopted the chair recognizes the
clerk Mr Speaker Senate Bill 499
relative to the supplemental nutrition
assistance program and the summer EBT
program and making Appropriations
therefore and relative to providing
disaster relief funding to
municipalities after a natural disaster
representative representative her
recommends that we adopt this committee
report are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I oppose nay no
the eyes have it the report is
adopted the clerk is recognized for
further Senate messages reports rather
Mr Speaker Senate Bill 555 relative to
receipt of pharmaceutical rebates by
insurers and Pharmacy benefit managers
representative
hunt representative hunt moves we adopt
the report are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the have it and the report is
adopted the chair recognizes the
clerk Mr Speaker Senate Bill 574
relative to the appointment of a
temporary agent for a minor child or
incapacitated person in relative to the
determination of parental rights and
responsibilities based on shared
parenting representative Mark Pearson
moves that we adopt the committee report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I oppose
nay the i7 the report is adopted the
clerk is Rec
recognized in one second he'll be
recognized the end of sen that's the end
of our Senate
bills
turn Mr Speaker before I step down I
just want to say to everybody you know
in New Hampshire they always argue what
the best view in the granted state is
and some say it's standing on Hampton
Beach and watching the sunrise in the
East and others say they say it's
standing on top of Mount Washington and
watching that beautiful sun set in the
west but for me Mr Speaker the best
viewer in the granite state is here at
this Podium looking at the best
legislators and the best legislative
staff in the country so I want to thank
you all thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you my friend
[Applause]
for what reason for what reason does a
member rise Mr Speaker I would move that
the great eloquent remarks from the
member from penac cook be entered into
the permanent journal without objection
chair recogniz uh the clerk for uh
reading the consent messages from the
consent calendar Mr Speaker the Senate
has adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference which was
referred the following entitled Bill
House Bill 194 requiring the director of
the division of historical resources to
compile and maintain a list of public
monuments in requiring legislative
approval of the amendment or permanent
removal of historical markers and House
Bill 10 30 repealing certain task forces
study committees and study commissions
repealing the John G W at Memorial
commission and making the maintenance of
the memorial a duty of the joint
legislative historical committee and
establishing a committee to study the
appeals process administered by the
environmental councils established RSA
under RSA 210 and House Bill 1274
relative to judicial
Administration representative Osborne
moves that consent calendar as we have
it is adopted are you ready for the
question question all those in favor say
I iose nay eyes have it the consent
calendar is adopted
take we do have a number of house bills
that we're going to start taking up we
don't have them all from the Senate yet
so they're not completely in order as we
usually do it in the house
chair recognizes the clerk for a senate
message Mr
Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following entitled Bill House Bill 318
relative to bail Commissioners the
standards applicable to and the
administration of bail and making an
appropriation representative moves that
we
ADT representative Roy moves that we
adopt the committee of conference report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I oppose nay eyes have it
report is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further sent house
message scitec declared a conflict on a
previous vote and did not vote
Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following entitled Bill House Bill 458
reestablished the commission to study
the assessing of power
generation representative o moves we
adopt the committee a conference report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay eyes
have it report is adopted chair
recognizes the clerk for a further
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference which has
referred the following titled Bill House
Bill 518 relative to the administration
of occupations by the office of
professional lure and certification
represent
Tony representative Tony leus moves that
we adopt the committee of conference
report are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it committee com
report is
adopted for further Senate message Mr
Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following titled Bill House Bill 1018
relative to on premise and off- premise
liquor licenses and relative to land and
current use representa hunt mes the ad
confence represent hunt moves that we
adopt the committee ACC competence
report Senator burrow is going to speak
against thank you Mr speaker
whoops sorry
MCE speech just slipped off here okay
currently landowners are get a 20%
discount on their property taxes if they
don't post the no trespassing sign and
keep it open for recreation without
charging a fee so if you put up a no
trespassing sign you don't get the 20%
discount um now what this bill would do
would be to post signs that say no
trespassing except for skiing
snowshoeing fishing hunting hiking or
nature observation and they'd be able to
keep the 20% discount the specific
Target of the law are people who are
crossing over the EXT extremely
extremely rural 58 mile border that New
Hampshire shares with
Canada this bill is being promoted as a
Border Protection me measure but what it
is is a plan designed to put limited
rural I'm sorry limited rural law
enforcement resources into a securing a
border that sees fewer incidents in a
year than the southern border sees in an
hour now the problem with this bill is
how do you differentiate between a
person who is who is hiking through
somebody's property to enjoy the great
outoors and hiking and doing those
activities or to versus somebody who may
have entered the country illegally and I
say that you can't um and I don't know
about you I don't I don't carry a
license I don't carry my passport when
I'm hiking
so if we passed this bill we'd have
limited state and local law enforcement
wandering through the woods asking
people to show their papers or show a
resque how many of you would bring your
papers or your passport going on a
hike so the bottom line the bottom line
is that this is a bill that that is
really unnecessary it's going to T tax
our local law enforcement and it's a a
bill in search of it's legislation in
search of a problem so I would urge you
to vote no with the committee of
conference of
report J recognized representative
hun okay Mr
Speaker uh this amendment is sort of a
red herring into this
bill this is is already law it's already
statute it is not about where you hike
it's over the entire
State anybody who has land in current
use is getting already a tax cut there
is a special tax cut an extra
20% if on your
sign your posted sign you say hiking is
permitted
you get an extra
20% what's the harm in
that how this thing turned into that
police are going to be storming people's
land and looking for driver's license is
it's total red herring has nothing to do
with this bill nobody is ever you know
questioned about why they're on
somebody's land hiking when it says the
land is posted for
hiking we need the liquor
bill this on premise on license on
premise license bill is a very important
it has a myriad of housekeeping issues
please pass this
bill the motion before us is to concur
on House
Bill to adopt the committee of
conference report on House Bill 1018 the
division has been requested
this will be a division vote members
take your seats
good
the motion before us to adopt the
committee conference report on House
Bill 10:18 this is a division
vote chair recognize represent burls for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that HB 1018 is legislation in search of
a problem and if I know that this bill
would put a a burden on limited law
enforcement officers and resources in
rural a in rural areas and if I know
that law enforcement will not be able to
distinguish between people enjoying the
great doors and people who have entered
this country illegally would I vote no
on concurrence with the committee of
conference chair recognize
representative hunt for a parliamentary
inquiry this bill has nothing Mr Speaker
this bill has nothing to do with
immigration this is an underlying liquor
bill that's very important housekeeping
measure and all I can say Mr Speaker is
it's already current law there's nothing
new in this legislation all it did
was would you believe that I don't know
where I am okay would you believe Mr
Speaker the legislation that is added is
added to the current use
law the reason being Mr Mr Speaker my
understanding is that it wanted to make
it clear that when people posted their
signs and said hiking was permitted that
they would not lose their tax credit Mr
Speaker well I now support all those
people who have current use land in the
state of New Hampshire by voting yes on
the prevailing motion the motion before
us is to adopt a committee of confence
report and House Bill 1018 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
secondses I'll get you represent
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also will attend to stay to the
vote 190 voting a 176 voting a Community
Conference reported
chair recognizes a clerk for a further
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which is
referred the following titled Bill House
Bill 1079 relative to CR critical
incident stress management team members
and establishing a rural and underserved
Area Educator incentive program for
higher education
and making an appropriation
therefore representative Gro moves that
we adopt the committee of conference
report are you ready for the question
all division has been requested members
take your seats this will be a division
vote for
the motion before us is to adopt the
committee of report on House Bill
1079 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds e
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote I'll will attend to stay to the
vote 241 voting a 125 voting a the
committee of conference report is
adopted Jer recog Isa clurk for a
further message Mr Speaker the Senate
has adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which was
referred the following entitled Bill
House Bill 1091 relative to the
financing of political campaigns
represent St
conference
report Representative Steven Smith moves
that we adopt the committee of
conference report and the chair
recognized representative Dan
Maguire thank you Mr Speaker this bill
is 17 pages long and it's a
comprehensive uh editing of our campaign
Finance uh laws most of it is is
perfectly benign and but I don't think
any of it is super
urgent but it does have serious uh
negative consequences for small dollar
donations what our current law says is
that when someone makes a donation to a
political Town committee or political
organization under
$50 it doesn't have to be
reported um individually you don't
report the person name you don't report
their address and so on you just report
you know you had an event maybe and you
raised uh $150 in small
donations um similarly what a current
law says is that when you do report name
so if it's over a donation is over
$50 you report the person's name and
address and if their total donation to
this organization over the period of
time
is over $200 then you also report their
occupation their employer and their
employer's address that's current
law what this bill
does is it wants to have reporting when
the aggregate donation of someone to
this organization becomes over
$50 so what it says is for every
donation regardless of sign SI that
person's donation name and address will
have to be
reported and then the and and the bill
also has people do all their reporting
online and so when the Secretary of
State's online system finds out that
this person's donation total becomes
over $50 then the Secretary of State's
online system will disclose that
person's name name and address the
problem with this is small town
committees who have simple events right
you you have a house party with a
donation bowl or you pass the hat or or
you have a 5050 or you have a raffle of
some kind all those small dollar
donations now will have to be
accompanied with a clipboard where
everybody who puts in $5 or puts
$10 is going to have to put in their
name and their full address and then the
treasurer of this organization is going
to have to go online and enter all of
this data um for every single donation
so this is a big burden on treasurers I
don't know if you've ever tried to you
know recruit people to be treasurers of
a town committee but it's not that easy
and this is just going to end up
discouraging people from particip
ipation in the political process and I
don't think it's necessary do we really
care when somebody puts in $10 this week
and two months from now they put it in
another 20 and so on I mean it's just
it's way too
burdensome and and not worth doing thank
you very much Mr
Speaker G I recognize repon M
quy thank you Mr Speaker
this bill is substantially similar to
the bill that passed back in March in
this
house I think the most substantive
change is that it made some adjustments
uh regarding uh reporting requirements
for the Senate
that uh put them on the same footing as
the executive
counsel uh instead of uh grouping them
together with all the down ticket races
thank you
the motion before us is to adopt the
committee conference report on House
Bill
1091 division has been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your
seats e
the motion before us to adopt the
committee confidence report and House
Bill 1091 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative wood for
parliamentary
inquiry thank thank you Mr
Speaker if I know this with uh House
Bill 1091 was worked on for two years
and pretty much just made this change in
the final uh uh bring uh final uh
CC if I know that the house
bill now puts restrictions on collecting
information name and address for all
donations if I know that the main reason
to collect it this information is to
ensure that there's no
undue um control of legislators and I
don't believe $50 would swing my vote at
all and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that I have constituents all the time
that ask me what the limit is and where
they can't be traced uh that's when they
where they make their decision I think
this will affect all especially State
reps that are running and with the $50
donations mean something I would vote
against I would vote red and vote
against the C uh report thank
you chair recognize representer quy for
a parliamentary
ining thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill is
substantially similar to the bill that
we passed back in
March and if I know that
uh the bill itself significantly re
clarifies and
simplifies a campaign Finance system
processes that candidates need to comply
with and that the public needs to depend
on to gain information about the
campaign Finance status of
candidates and if I agree that it
strikes a good balance between
transparency of uh campaign Finance uh
activities and
uh with reducing and controlling the
administrative burden for candidates and
the public would I then press the green
button to agree with the committee of
conference report thank you very
much the motion before us is the
adoption of the committee conference
report on House Bill 1091 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're oppose
you'll press a red button voting
stations open 30 seconds
represent LAN
all members present had an opportunity
to vote how attendance St of the
vote under 90 voting a 181 voting aay
committing ACR report is adopted
I um am big for tradition and past
practices I think it's one of the more
important things we do in this body one
of our past practi practices is the
final day of session the speaker allows
the minority leader to come up and do a
couple of bills when I was minority
leader back in
1910 that was converted upon me to come
up and speak I mean and to run the
session for a few bills and thus I'm
going to ask the minority leader to come
up and cover a few bills for us and
return to our Trad return to our
tradition
[Applause]
the house will be attentive to the clerk
Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which is referred the
following entitled Bill House Bill
1195 relative to allowing school
districts to approve different
apportionment methods for school
administrative unit
costs representative lad moves that we
adopt the committee of conference
report are we ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those
opposed say
nay the motion is adopted
the house will be attentive to the
clerk Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted
the recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following titled Bill House Bill 122
relative to the issuance of permits for
the alteration of driveways ex exiting
onto public ways and relative to the
definition of disability or special
needs under the child care scholarship
program repres
representative mcon moves that we adopt
the committee of conference report are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all oppos say
nay the eyes have it and the committee
report is
adopted
okay recognize the clerk Mr Speaker the
Senate has adopted the recommendation of
the committee of con conference to which
is referred the following title bill
House Bill 1215 relative to development
approvals and appeals and allowing the
town of Hampton to discontinue a
particular Highway in order to lease
that
property representative Alexander moves
that we adopt the committee of
conference report
the chair recognizes representative Len
turkot thank you Mr
Speaker just two weeks ago we this body
voted against hp1 1215 which included
the amendment I'm going to speak in
opposition to again after its defeat
last time it was sent to a committee of
conference where the house positioned
should have been argued for it was not
and now we have before you the exact
same bill that we've already voted down
briefly the amendment 1215 would allow
the board of Selectmen in Hampton to
discontinue a road in the beach area and
rent that road up to 99 years to a
private business this would bypass the
normal process contained in our rsas
where the town votes on whether to allow
such an action New Hampshire law is very
specific that town residents are the
local legislative body to who are who
are empowered to both discontinue roads
and lease the property now the last time
we heard this amendment before this body
the main excuse given was that it was
needed because the amendment was time
critical that argument was negated as it
was ACC accurately pointed out that it
takes less than two months for the town
meeting process to play out and that the
town citizens could have already voted
on this in fact in early September
primaries will be held giving the town
the ability to call a special meeting
and vote on the issue with very minimal
costs now one of the latest excuses
being used is that the 99-year lease
requires an immediate irsa change that's
factually incorrect 100% false the
current rsas allow both the
discontinuance of roads and leases to be
adjudicated by the voters using the town
meeting process the rsas allow the
Selectmen to lease up to 5 years without
voter approve approval over 5 years it
requires a vote voter approval just in a
town meeting just like the
discontinuance of a
road next several times the uh the blur
in the calendar mentions that this is
enabling legislation let's be really
clear on this point the only thing
enabling about this amendment is it
enables the Selectmen to bypass the
voters of
Hampton the other excuse being put forth
is this a oneoff uh is that one-offs are
done all the time personally I've never
seen anything close to a one-off such as
the one before you and if we believe
which I do not that these one-offs
happen all the time then it's time to
end them when we change our or add rsas
they should apply to every municipality
not a single not Town not a single
project as this amendment attempts to do
just imagine if this RSA change would
have been proposed for all
municipalities on a permanent basis can
you even imagine the Uproar and
Universal outrage over this so in
conclusion the chairman of Municipal and
County government of the other other
body is against this bill the chairman
and mun of Municipal and County
government in this body is against this
bill our opposition to the bill is not
about Hampton or the developers of the
project or the project itself it's about
property rights of the abutters the town
citizens voting rights being arreated we
believe in fewer regul ations that are
pro business but they must be
advantageous to every business the issue
is also about consistency versus
arbitrariness this body should never do
one-offs or place temporary special
exemptions into our rsas for the
potential benefit of a few individuals
while negating the rights of their
citizens and the issue is about this
body not setting a terrible precedent
that could affect many Property Owners
throughout our state in the future
and above all and this is very important
the vote you were about to make will
show whether you support ethical
legislative policies and
procedures or not I ask that you vote
right against this motion of concur Mr
Speaker I've already submitted or roll
call vote has been requested thank you
Mr
Speaker roll call has been
requested uh
I wouldn't take that
up
okay the chair
recognizes representative
stavis thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker my colleague has
spoken against hb12 15's non- gerine
Amendment and I Rise to speak against
the underlying bill proposal that will
not achieve the goals set forth by its
sponsors according to those sponsors
this bill will create more housing in
New Hampshire but rather than providing
substantive initiatives it only seeks to
change the existing and successful law
that exempts developers from code and
land use regulation changes while their
projects are moving
forward supporters of the bill argued in
Committee of conference that such code
code and ordinance changes are
sidelining developers because they lose
time and money in the process and
ultimately find their projects are no
longer profitable but in fact current
law prevents that from happening RSA
67439 the law hb1 1215 seeks to amend
exempts developers from any such changes
for a full two years after planning
board approval if they achieve active
and substantial progress in that time
frame they then have another 5 years to
reach substantial completion again
exempt from all code and ordinance
changes if that is the case and those of
us who sit on planning boards know that
it is the case then perhaps we should
examine why hb125 supporters claim this
radical change is so desperately needed
developers they say need twice as much
time as current law allows they need
five years to achieve active progress
and 10 years to achieve substantial
completion the majority of the municipal
and County government committee which
exists to understand and improve the
land use law hb125 seeks to change
agrees by a wide and bipartisan margin
that these propos proposed new time
frames are
excessive what's more they will result
in less not more housing for New
Hampshire residents by robbing towns of
their ability to move on from projects
that are clearly not successful to
pursue better and more successful
proposals hb1 1215 also makes the Bold
assumption that all New Hampshire
developers need this very generous time
frame when the majority of our
communities have seen subdivisions
multif family buildings and other types
of homes take shape in less than five
years I urge my colleagues to think
about the circumstances that might cause
a developer to need a full decade of
exemptions in our experience in Lebanon
those circumstances have included
stopping projects to pursue more
lucrative ones elsewhere in the state or
simple
mismanagement there's a good reason why
67439 allows 2 and 5year exemption
phases they allow ample time for a
well-run project to shake take shape and
be completed while protecting towns and
cities from developers who delay to
enhance their bottom lines or just can't
get the work
done hb1 1215 will not generate new
housing in New Hampshire it will do just
just the opposite it will allow a full
decade to elapse between approval and
completion a decade in which this
legislature will have passed new
building codes and towns will have
enacted new ordinances to improve
building and Energy Efficiency none of
which will apply to housing projects
should this Committee of conference
report be
adopted this is a bill that will
undoubtedly be good for some developers
but bad for New Hampshire citizens who
desperately need places to
live it will result in less not more
housing and will impose a heavy-handed
Statewide mandate that will leave towns
saddled with long-term unsuccessful
development projects taking up land and
resources that really would produce more
housing in less time I urge you to vote
no on adopting the committee of
conference report recommendation for
hp215 thank you Mr
Speaker the chair recognizes
representative
power thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of the motion to adopt the
committee of conference report on House
Bill 1215
this bill has four sections I will speak
specifically to section
four section four provides the Hampton
Selectmen a short limited window of
opportunity to act if they choose on the
following first is to dis discontinue a
435 ft portion of D Street Which is less
than a tenth mile long second is to
enter into a long longterm lease of the
discontinued portion of the road with
the abutter who owns all of the
properties on both sides of this short
section of roadway importantly the
abutter is in full agreement with the
discontinuation of the road now some
feel that this legislation is
unnecessary and say that a special town
meeting or an annual town meeting can
accomplish what is in section four of
the bill
while it is correct that a special or
annual town meeting can vote to
discontinue a road the issue is that the
law is not clear regarding long-term
leases of town
property it is clear that there are at
least two options under RSA
411a number one Selectmen are given the
blanket authority to enter into a lease
of town property for up to one year and
number two select Selectmen may be
authorized to enter into a lease of up
to five years by a vote of the
legislative body at an annual or special
town
meeting additionally many agree that a
lease agreement for a period of more
than a year requires a vote by the town
but what is not clear and is not
properly understood by many is that for
a lease agreement longer than 5 years
the legislative body is required to vote
every five years to reauthorize the
Selectmen to continue the lease
otherwise the lease terminates I believe
that this is a true and accurate
interpretation based on the recent
application of this law
411a and my own own town of
Brookline to explain in 2019 voters in
Brookline passed a warrant article to
allow the Selectmen to lease Town land
on a on a pond to multiple tenants for
years since the 13year leases were
longer than 5 years 411a requires voter
approval every 5 years as a result at
our 2024 town meeting a warrant article
to allow the Selectmen to extend these
leases for an additional five years was
voted on and was passed by the
voters and in 2029 the Brookline voters
will be asked again to vote to allow the
Selectmen F to further extend these
leases for an additional three years to
get to the 13 years which brings me to
this very important final
point in light of differing legal
interpretations of
411a if a special town meeting in
Hampton under sb2 voted to discontinu D
Street and also to approve a long-term
lease of D Street for longer than 5
years it is unclear that a long-term
lease would stand up up to Legal review
by any institution financing the project
or to any other legal challenges
moreover with the real possibility that
a long-term lease is interpreted to be
valid for only five years no bank will
finance a multi-million dollar project
due to the risk that the lease might not
be renewed therefore it is clear that a
special or even annual town meeting
approach is legally risky at best to
conclude given the ambiguous language of
411a it is entirely appropriate for the
state legislature to address this issue
through
legislation section four of House Bill
1215 provides a clear well-defined
process free of legal uncertainty to the
time of Hampton through their Selectmen
to discontinue and then lease D Street
enabling an appropriate project design
proposal to then be finalized to go
before the Hampton planning and zoning
boards therefore I urge my fellow
colleagues to support the committee of
conference
report for a house bill 1215 by voting
yes thank you Mr Speaker
the chair recognizes representative
Penza thank you Mr Speaker honorable
members I rise in opposition to H Bill
1215 as was amended by the other body my
reasons are as follows we already killed
this Hampton Amendment two weeks
ago and when the PE and when when the
bill went to the committee of conference
nothing changed and our position which
is the people's position was completely
ignored even though the committee of
conference members were again given the
factual information about why the
amendment needed to be
rejected and that if the Hampton
Amendment wasn't removed the bill needed
to die it doesn't matter it was
ignored it is beyond disrespectful and
frankly an absolute waste of everyone's
time in this body when a majority is
ignored because of a select few personal
agendas it is unconscionable that there
are several representatives in this room
that have been silenced and or are
afraid of speaking out on this
borderline fraudulent Amendment which
circumvents the rights of Hampton voters
in fear of Retribution from legislative
power Brokers of losing their reelection
from party influence it is even worse
that filling the pockets of preferred
political candidates in Senate and House
packs must might have influenced pushing
through this amendment today we stand at
a critical juncture in our
constitutional republic our political
system designed to represent the will of
the people the member will suspend it's
getting a little noisy in
here member has a right to be heard
member may continue thank you our
political system designed to represent
the will of the people is under constant
threat from conquered parking garages to
no bid contract property giveaways to to
Buddies to Laconia land grabs and more
we have some real ethical and integrity
problems under this gold Dome and many
have decided not to run again because of
it the Insidious influence of money and
politics has corroded the very
foundations of our constitutional
republic turning what should be a
government of by and for the people into
a government of by and for the highest
bitter that is not this is not about
whether this project is a good idea or
not I grew up going to the hamping
casino ballroom since I actually was in
high school and it would be wonderful to
have a new venue because the property
has become pretty rundown this is only
about the process and the passing
something that cuts out
16.5 th000 Plus Hampton residents who do
not who are the ones that actually have
the skin in the game here they are the
taxpayers and they need to make the
decision if they want this it is not our
place to circum invent their voice in
their vote the member will
suspend we're not to ascribe
motive this is wrong every time
everywhere we we look to see politicians
beholden the special interests
legislation crafted not for the common
good for the benefit of wealthy donors
in a system that disproportionately
favors the voices of the Rich and
Powerful over those of ordinary citizens
this culture has eroded public trust in
our institutions and undermined the Very
princip principles upon which we were
founded I was taught if you see
something you need to say something so I
will never stand stay silent and allow
this to continue while I am a member of
the body I try very hard to be a
representative for the people we cannot
sit oddly by as the voices of people are
drowned out and in this case cut out by
the Roar of corporate interests we must
reclaim our constitutional republic and
restore power to the hands of the people
we must banish the corrosive practices
where access and influence are bought
and sold like Commodities we must
Institute robust transparency measures
to ensure that the public knows who is
attempting to buy influence or and for
what purpose even if that means it will
only be exposed by one representative at
a time most importantly we must also
work to empower ordinary citizens and
amplify their voices in the political
process because we work for them we need
to teach them to instruct us because as
we all should know they are our bosses
the forces armed against this level of
Engagement are powerful and well funded
but throughout history whenever our
constitutional republic was threatened
ordinary citizens have RI risen up to
demand change today I stand up here with
the courage and the determination to say
not on my watch let us all come together
across party lines and ideological
divides and defeat hb1 1215 let us show
that we want to operate in a political
system that truly represents the will of
the people in this case the thousands of
Hampton residents let us never forget
that the power to bring about change
lies not in the hands of the few but in
the collective will of the many please
vote R and oppose the committee report
thank
you the chair recognizes representative
muns thank you Mr Speaker and uh good
morning colleagues
I rise in support of the committee of
conferences report on hb1
1215 the Hampton Beach Casino ballroom
is not a large gaming venue the name
Casino goes back to
1899 when it was established as a dance
hall for at least the past 50 years it
has been a music venue hosting popular
groups such as the Beach Boys Bonnie
rayot and when they were just starting
out years ago you twoo the ballroom is
the engine that drives the economy at
Hampton Beach and it contributes
significantly to the economic well-being
of New Hampshire people come to the
ballroom to see a show go out to eat at
a local restaurant which generates rooms
and meals tax
revenue but it has reached the end of
its useful life and the owners of the
ballroom know that it needs to be
replaced in addition to owning the site
upon which the existing
if we're having conversations we should
be taking them into the anti
room in addition to owning the site upon
which the existing Ballroom sits which
is between D and F streets the owners of
the ballroom also own a parcel of land
to the north between D and C streets
they want to integrate that land into
the footprint of the new development
they are
proposing before the owners can submit
their final design plans to the local
plan planning and zoning boards they
need to know if D Street will be closed
if the project is
approved they also need to know if the
town is willing to enter into a
long-term lease for land under the
street current law as you heard only
permits leases up to 5
years now a few things about D Street it
is a
500 500t side street that sits on public
land in an urban area
with no homes on it that runs between
two Parcels of land owned by the same
land owner our Public Safety officials
have indicated there would be no Public
Safety or traffic issues if the road is
closed in fact traffic flow will
probably be improved if the proposed
Redevelopment project is completed there
is no issue of eminent domain or taking
of private land since available
historical records indic indicate that
the land underneath D Street is already
owned by the town of
Hampton I know many of you are
struggling with the fact that the voters
of Hampton would not have a direct say
in whether the road should be closed I
struggled that I struggled with that
myself and that is why when I wrote the
amendment I specified that the select
board can only make a decision to close
the road after they hold public hearing
public meetings with the Hampton
planning board the Hampton Beach Village
district and the Hampton Beach area
commission and they hold two public
hearings that does not skirt the process
of Civic involvement it provides for at
least five public hearings which is
significantly more opportunity for
public input than a single deliberative
session for input furthermore I have
enough confidence in our selected board
or select board which was in fact which
was after all elected by the people that
they will respect the opinion they
receive particularly if they want to get
reelected many of you may have also seen
a letter written by one of our select
board members I know and respect that
member but you need to know that her
opinion is hers alone and does not
reflect the opinion of our board in
addition you also need to know that both
our town manager and another member of
that same select board testified in
favor of the amendment to HB 1215 when
the senate committee on elections and
Municipal Affairs held their public
meeting you also need to know that the
Hampton Area Chamber of Commerce
supports hb1
1215 I know that by now all of you have
seen a copy of their letter of
support finally you need to know that
except for one person speaking out
against hb1 1215 at a recent select
board meeting there has been no local
outcry against either hb5 uh 1215 or the
proposed Redevelopment and I have only
received one email asking me about it
most of the people in Hampton I have
talked to are very supportive of this
project and the process we are
proposing and that is another point to
remember what hb1 1215 does is provide
the Hampton select board with an
alternative process they can choose to
use to close D Street there is nothing
in the bill that mandates or guarantees
a specific outcome not with respect to
whether D Street should be closed or
that the or what the terms of a
long-term lease might be or certainly
not whether the Redevelopment project
should go forward the owners of the
project understand that they are going
to have to go before the Hampton
planning board and the Hampton zoning
board to obtain their their approval all
they're asking for right now is some
clarity on whether they can include the
land underneath D Street in their final
plans we have all received emails
expressing concerns about the precedent
that we the legislature would be setting
if we were to pass hb1
12415 according to house committee
Services since
1999 there have been at least eight
instances where legislation was brought
forward to approve a specific action or
provide specific special legislative
permission required for or requested by
municipality most recently this year we
provided a one-time payment of
$191,000 to the town of
Hamstead in addition if we are setting a
unique precedent by passing hb1 1215 it
is a very narrow one we would be
providing a select board elected by the
people with an option between now and
next march to say it will close a 500t
side street that sits on public land in
an ear urban area with no homes on it
that runs between two Parcels of land
owned by the same landowner and then
leasing that land to the landowner if a
project proposed by the land order is
approved in accordance with local land
use regulations I don't know if you can
get any narrower than
that finally we the state did our our
part 15 or 20 years ago when we upgraded
the infrastructure along the east side
of Ocean Boulevard and it looks fabulous
since since then there has been some
private Redevelopment but we needed the
owners of the ballroom to step up and
redevelop that property they are now
willing and eager to do so and they are
not asking for any direct investment of
public money in fact they have already
indicated that if there is any
infrastructure under D Street that needs
to be relocated they will pay for that
this is our opportunity to reach out and
offer them the very small helping hand
they are asking for and demonstrate that
we really do believe in public private
Partnerships please join me in
supporting the this Committee of
conference report and pushing the green
button thank you very
much does the member yield to a
question
yes thank you Mr speak I'm sorry the
member
yields representative Ville you're
recognized for a question thank you Mr
speaker thank you representative for for
taking the question I I know it's
getting late in the day already and I
won't take up too much time you keep
talking about the public hearings that
that have to be held is there any legal
requirement that uh compels elected
officials to vote or act in a manner
consistent with the majority position
expressed during a public
hearing none that I'm none that I'm
aware of but I believe that applies to
the members of this body body as well
there is nothing that compels us to vote
necessarily the way uh a majority of the
people in our town want us to vote thank
you for taking the question thank you Mr
Speaker will the member yield to another
question
sure representative Roy is recognized
for a question member yields thank you
Mr speaker thank you for taking my
question I just I heard a new data point
from both speakers and I'm curious so
I'm a bank the ballroom comes to me and
says we'd like to borrow $175 million
we're going to redo our whole Cino and
we're going to really build this thing
out nice and I say well how are you
going to pay me back and they say well
over 20 years we're going to pay you
back so much from the profits and here
our profit sheets this so much we
usually
make and and then I say okay but what's
this here about every five years so in
five years the voters could shut you
down and all my money would be gone is
that the
case I couldn't have said that better
myself yes that that would be a problem
for a bank uh if they saw that uh that
provision representative cutab has
requested a roll call and it's been
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members please take your
[Music]
seats
e e
the house will come to
order the chair recognizes
representative magori for parliamentary
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know the right way the proper way to
address any ambiguity and statute would
be through the bill process that we go
through which begins in January not
through a non- gerain Amendment and if I
know the current state law says that
once you have local approval of a
development you have two
years to initiate active construction
and if that is done within 2 years you
receive an additional threeyear
exemption from any changes in land use
law and if I know that there is
substantial completion after 5 years
developers are permanently protected
from changes to land use regulation
changes and if I know that time
increases cost then would I reject this
needless doubling of exemptions by
pressing the red button to reject this
Bill thank you Mr Speaker
the chair recognizes representative
O'Neal for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the Hampton Beach Casino
ballroom is not a gaming venue but one
of New Hampshire's leading music venues
that is seeking to redevelop and upgrade
the property at their own expense and
with the support of the Hampton Chamber
of Commerce and if I know that to
finalize and present their design to the
appropriate local planning and zoning
boards for their approval the owners
would like Clarity on whether D Street
will be closed and the property can be
leased for 99 years and if I know that
under current law towns are only able to
lease land they own for no longer than 5
years and thus need legislative action
to assist the town to lease the property
and if I know that holding a special
town meeting to decide whether to close
D Street would not only cost over
$15,000 but conflict with the state
primary and general elections and impose
an undue burden on the residents of
Hampton and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that if we adopt this Committee of
conference report Hampton will continue
to have local control of the of the
decision whether to close D Street and
whether to approve or not approve the
proposed Redevelopment of the ballroom
would I now press the green button to
Grant the Hampton select board the
option if they choose to exercise it
between now and March 2025 to decide to
close D Street and Lease the land
underneath it for up to 99 years but
only after they have had have held five
public hearings where the voters of
Hampton will be able to express their
opinion thank you Mr Speaker the
question is on the adoption of the
committee of conference report of House
Bill 1215 this is a roll call vote if
you are in favor you will push the green
button if you are opposed you will push
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
represent goalie
I got you
have all members had an opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote with
102 members voting
yay and 261 voting
nay the motion
fails
represent a motion representative Cahill
is recognized for a
motion thank you Mr Speaker I I would
like to have the remarks printed from
the previous debate in the perent
journal without objection
[Applause]
okay the ice cream is
ready uh we will recess until
1:45
e
e e
recogn chair recognizes the clerk for a
senate
message members take your
seats Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted
the recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following titled Bill House Bill
1197 relative to criminal background
checks and relative to insurance
coverage for intrauterine
insemination
[Music]
represent representative Roy moves we
adopt the committee of convence report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I iose nay the eyes have it
and the report is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for a
furthest
message Mr
Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference report to which is referred
the following entitled Bill House Bill
1236 establishing a pilot pilot
Recruitment and Retention program within
the Department of Health and Human
Services in relative to the income
eligibility for in and out of medical
assistance under the State Medicaid plan
representative hunt ad the conference
representative hunt moves we adopt the
committee of conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
iOS n the eyes have Committee of
conference report is adopted chair
recognize the clerk for further
message Mr
Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following titled Bill House Bill 1241
relative to the regulation of money
transmitters and relative to license
applications and renewals for certain
Consumer Credit
entities
H repres hunt moves that we adopt the
committee of conference report chair
recognize representa bogert
Mr speaker thank
you I rise today to speak about hb1
1241 I originally Al was going to stand
up and speak in opposition to the
bill but I've changed my
mind as
anybody as every legislator should
maintain an open mind I've had
conversations with several people during
lunch and I actually went and had a
conversation at the
treasury so that I could understand
totally what the words mean because
Words As We Know mean everything
especially when you're dealing with
shs because that's
mandatory and what was the other word
they used was
strive so no one strives to lose so if
you're striving to do something
different then you're you're using a
mandatory positive force so in my
conversations
that this fund and its board that
oversees the fund is not going to do
much uh to have an adverse effect on the
AAA Bond rating that we have and that
depends on the deposits and everything
we put in our Pat
fund the money that was being talked
about was what's called float
there's money that's kept in cash
because you
have monies that come in monies that go
out and that money has to be kept
somewhere because it's not invested to
where you get that great return that we
all expect and have seen it's deposited
in the banks so basically after reading
the three sentences and stuff it's kind
of of a
[Music]
non-harmful shot across the bow as one
might say where the banks are going what
can we do to get a little
more they hold a seat on that Bond
Council and it was surprising they
didn't go to the bond Council they chose
to go through the legislative process
trying to do something that's neither
here nor there but since I've been
talking to a lot of people
about trying to defeat this I wanted to
stand here and
say because I have new information that
my mind has changed and I think it would
be okay to pass this
Bill thank
you chair recognizes representative hunt
waves off the motion before is concur on
house Cur on the committee of conference
report on House Bill 1241 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I iose
nay the eyes have it and the committee
conference report is
adopted J recognizes the clerk for a
further
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which was
referred the following title bill House
Bill 1243 revising the laws relative to
retail installment sales of Motor
Vehicles and relative to the sale of a
vehicle to a Massachusetts
resident move to
table represent hunt moves that we adopt
the committee of conference report for
what reason does a member
rise a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion I move that the question be laid
on the table and ask for a division
vote the motion is to table House Bill
a division has been requested members
take your
seats e
the motion before us is the is to is to
table House Bill
1243 subvision vote chair recognized
Representative Steven Smith for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this conference
report should not be on the calendar
today because Mr Speaker if I know that
in my haste to get everything done in
the few minutes before the deadline on
Thursday I inadvertently signed off my
friend from hooked who did not want to
sign off on the report and Mr Speaker if
I know that I had done my job properly
we wouldn't be having this conversation
would I ask the Indulgence of the house
and helping me correct that error by
pressing the green
button chair recognize representative
hunt for a parliamentary inquiry
okay I'm going to get this right Mr
Speaker if I know I have total
respect for the deputy and that his
offering to do something to make it
right is a very worthy cause but Mr
Speaker if I know this is a 20page bill
related to recodification of retail
sales of
automobiles and we would be uh laps to
not pass this at this time will I please
vote no of the pending motion Mr speaker
so that we can take up a no on the
tabling so we can
concur the motion before us is the table
House Bill 1243 this a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds e
[Music]
represent rich
all members present at the opportunity
to vote house will attend to stay to the
vote 146 voting aay 202 voting aay the
motion fails we're back to the original
motion of a to pass Committee of
conference report adopting the committee
conference report on 1243 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I I suppose
nay eyes have it Committee of conference
report is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which was
referred the following titled Bill House
Bill 1259 relative to Property and
Casualty Insurance laws administered by
the insurance department and making an
appropriation to the Department of
Environmental Services to fund Regional
drinking water
infrastructure hunt moves we adop we
adopt the committee of conference report
on House Bill 1259 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose n the eyes have it
Committee of conference report is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following title bill House Bill 1265
relative to the penalty for failure to
vile School expenditure reports relative
to certain adequacy grants and requiring
mandatory reporting by school districts
of school expenses
lad lad moves we adopt the committee
conference report chair recognizes
representative Damon
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
colleagues House Bill 1265 with s SP 219
attached requires school districts to
post expense information in a very
prescriptive way it violates local
control and even prohibits reasonable
explanation of budgets on the posters
that are required providing budget
information without acknowledging the
many changes in what we require of
public schools is deliberately
misleading and
inflammatory this bill literally
specifies the paper size to be used talk
about
micromanagement all of the information
requested by the bill is currently
readily available on the Department of
Education website so simply publicizing
that link on School District websites
would be effective communication please
join me in pressing the red button to
defeat this unnecessary
Bill jerich and eyes representative dry
thank you Mr
speaker part one of the bill is just
housekeeping it takes private acmis out
of a list so they don't have to file
paperwork that they don't have to
file but part two says that before
budget meetings school districts will
have to present to voters three simple
graphs the average cost per pupil the
average teacher
salary and the administrative salaries
and how they've trended over the past 10
years and we'll have to present one
table that lists the top four
administrative salaries in the district
and their titles this bill contains a
civil remedy section similar to our
current RSA
91a and it would allow taxpayers to peti
petition the court if this information
is not provided according to law finally
the committee of conference just
tightened up the definitions of what
appears in the graphs so that we'll be
comparing Apples to
Apples but can't people find this
information on their own well the
average taxpayer doesn't know where to
look for this information and even if
they do it would take a lot of digging
on the doeo website and School District
websites but it's easy for a school
district to get this information and to
put it together
why would we want the information
besides the fact that a picture is worth
a thousand words we'll learn some things
like maybe that per pupil costs have
risen over the past 10 years but teacher
salaries have had a minimal increase in
comparison or maybe that some
administrators are making three times
what the average teacher salary is the
transparency provided in the
graphs helps taxpayers make more
informed decision
decisions so how do we get this valuable
information for everyone it's simple
vote Yes and adopt the committee of
conference report Mr Speaker I request a
division
vote V request a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
we e
the motion before us is the to accept
the committee of concer report on 12
House Bill 1265 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Cornell
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that almost all of this information
is already available on the Department
of Education website under if Finance if
I know that this bill requires districts
to report budget data on graphs on two
pages that are 18 by 24 with only the
name and logo of the district to be
displayed in two places of business and
in a local paper and if I know that if
any explanation of this that any
explanation of this data is prohibited
and subject to a civil penalty so if you
agree with me that posting data with no
explanation is misleading and also
disrespectful to elected school boards
and to the public please join me in
pushing the red button to put an end to
this unnecessary and disrespectful
Bill chair recognized representative
Noble for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill removes the requirement
that publicy file Financial reports with
the Department of
Education if I know that this bill would
require school districts to provide the
taxpayers with three simple line graphs
showing the average cost per pupil
average teacher salaries and
administrator salaries over a period of
10 years and one table showing the top
four administrator salaries and titles
if I know that the average taxpayer
doesn't know how to find this
information but school districts have
all the data and can easily provide it
in this clear and accessible
format if I know that our local schools
rely heavily on local taxpayer dollars
and they should know where their money
is being spent and how that investment
is trending over
time and if I know that providing this
transparency to the taxpayers will help
to promote productive local
conversations about spending what I now
support
transparency by pressing the green
button thank
you the motion before us is the
committee of conference report of hb1
1265 if you're in this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppos you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds e
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote Al will attend to stay of the
vote 183 voting yay 1712 voting nay
committee conference report is
adopted CH recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message
Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which is referred the
following titled Bill House Bill 1278
relative to qualifying medical
conditions for purposes of therapeutic
cannabis and relative to the summer EBT
program the snap elderly simplified
application and the school lunch program
and making Appropriations
therefore represent
Lees representa Lon moves we adopt the
committee of conference report
the motion before us is to adopt the
committee of conference report in House
Bill 1278 are you ready for the question
all those in
favor Mr Speaker House Bill 1278 was on
the consent calendar as the speaker
mentioned earlier the Senate did not
take up their bills in numerical order
and thus they sent over messages in
staggering processes because it's the
other body um and I would just note that
because we adopted the consent calendar
as we had it at the time
those bills have been disposed of
unfortunately anything else that was on
the consent calendar you do need to
adopt
individually representative Lon has
moved the adoption of the commit of
conference report are you ready for the
question who requested a roll call
okay are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppos
nay the eyes have it and committee ACC
confence report is adopted chair
recognize the clerk for a further Senate
message Mr
Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which is referred the
following titled Bill House Bill 1127
relative to the revocation and
suspension of driver's licenses and to
in invalidating out ofate driver's
licenses issued to undocumented
immigrants representative Walch moves we
adopt the committee a conference report
on 1127 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I suppose they the eyes have it a
committee of conference report is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for a
further Senate message
chair chair recognizes a clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate has adopted a recommendation of
the committee of conference to which was
referred the following entitled Bill
House Bill
1292 relative to coverage of children
under the state retiree insurance plan
and relative to Federal immigration
enforcement representative Roy moves
adoption of the committee of conference
report on House Bill 1292 for what
reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I Rise to make a motion
State your motion Mr Speaker I would
move to table this bill and um I would
ask for a division
the motion is a proper motion to table
House Bill
1292 this will be a division vote
members take your seats
you want to do a pi
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 1292 this is a division vote chair
recognizes represent marjerie Smith for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that immigration
portions of this bill are exactly the
same as Senate Bill
563 that this house tabled on May 2nd of
this year and if I know that enforce law
enforcement have not supported its en
enactment and have in fact concerned
that prior versions of this
bill
um require local police do the work of
the federal federal
government concerning federal civil
immigration enforcement without any
funds for training or
compliance and if I know that the New
Hampshire Association of counties
opposes this bill because it puts County
correctional facilities in a vulnerable
position opening the county to
litigation and because County
correctional facilities have the ability
to hold only on state charges not
federal and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill would require local
police to detain people
pursuant to immigration detainers that
lack due process and are issued without
a warrant or judicial oversight and we
know that hundreds of US citizens have
been held in error on detainers would I
now press the green button and table
House Bill
1292 thank you Mr Speaker the motion
before us is a table House Bill 1292
this say division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposer press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
get
[Music]
all members president had the
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 192 voting a 165 voting aay House
Bill 1292 is light on the
table for what purpose do a member rise
I would like to have the comments of hb1
1265 put in the permanent
journal without objection thank
you J recogniz the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which is
referred the following titled Bill House
Bill 13313 relative to access to the
voter checklist by candidates represent
St Representative Steven Smith moves we
adopt the Committee of conference report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I oppose nay the eyes have
it the committee of conference report is
adopted chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate has adopted the recommendation of
the committee of conference to which is
referred the following titled Bill House
Bill 1358 relative to tenants and
contract manufacturers of beer wined
excuse me wine and liquor allowing
pharmacists to administer influenza
covid-19 and other FDA licensed vaccines
without explicit approval from The
General court and restricting the
purchase of real property on or around
military
installations represent hunt moves we
adopt the committee of conference report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose
nay eyes have it the committee of
conference report is adopted the chair
recognizes the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate is
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which is
referred the following title bill House
Bill 1369 relative to the verification
of voter roles every four
years representative stepen Smith moves
we adopt the committee of confidence
report chair recognizes representative
Mirad thank you Mr
Speaker this bill would
compel local supervisors of the
checklist to purge voter registration
lists every four years instead of the
current interval of 10
years the consequence will be that many
thousands of New Hampshire citizens will
routinely find that when they go to the
polls to vote their name is not on the
voting
list that will cause confusion
indignation and
anger not to mention delays as perfectly
qualif ified taxpaying New Hampshire
citizens find they have to use a
provisional ballot and pro and produce
documentation proving citizenship and
residence and age even though they've
already done
that many
citizens only vote in presidential
elections many citizens only vote once
every four years they don't vote in town
elections Party primary elections
midterm
elections and many of those will
occasionally skip a presidential
election sometimes because imagine this
they don't like either of the candidates
nominated by the major
parties sometimes because they can't get
off work so they miss an
election under this bill those voters
presidential election voters who Skip
One election
will be at risk to have their names
purged from the voting
list that experience I predict will
amplify those voters sense of
alienation from the formal institutions
of
government from the
parties from voting
itself I think it will cause it will
enlarge the class of those citizens who
are Perman
non-voters yes to be
sure before your name is Struck from the
list you'll receive a postcard from the
supervisors of the
checklist asking you to
respond and defend your right to
vote some will respond and their name
will stay on the checklist but
others will not they'll be confused
about why they're receiving a postcard
why are they a Cit citizen who hasn't
moved whose residence hasn't changed
whose status as a citizen hasn't changed
at all why do they have to defend their
right to vote they'll be confused about
that and they'll wonder what's
up some will just not see the postcard I
don't know about your house but in in my
house my children seem to think that
everything that arrives in the mail is
recycling I'm lucky if I I see it at
all this bill will
disenfranchise
voters yes I agree with the purpose of
this bill voting lists have to be
maintained in good order people move
alas people
die our lists have to be
updated there's an excellent way to do
that
over a decade ago election officials in
seven states four of which were LED at
the time by Republican Governors
launched the electronic registration
information center known in short as
Eric it's since come to include 30
States according to Eric every 60 days a
lot more frequently than the four-year
interval that this bill would impose
every 60 days
every Eric State submits voter
registration Motor Vehicle Registration
licensing data allowing Eric to see
which voters have moved and change
districts and update lists accordingly
that's the lowcost super accurate
solution to maintaining voting lists
this bill by contrast is not a solution
to anything it will make our voting list
less accurate not more accurate it will
confuse our citizenry it will make
citizens angry it will force law-abiding
taxpaying citizens to defend their right
to vote for no reason whatsoever it will
disenfranchise lots of citizens and it
will create a permanent class of
non-voters suspicious and alienated this
bill is not a solution to a problem it's
a whole new bundle of problems we should
oppose
it vote against the committee report I
would urge you so that we can non-c
concur thank
you chair recogniz from Senator
qua thank you Mr
Speaker this bill is passed by the
house would indeed
Institute an update of the checklist
every four years the house version had a
four-year look back meaning they would
check the previous four years to see if
someone on the checklist had
voted the position as agreed between the
Senate and the house in the committee of
conference exceeded to the Senate's
preference for a six-year look back
period I did the I did the math someone
can check me if I'm right but I count 14
elections in each jurisdiction during
that six years that means in order to be
removed from the checklist under this
bill you would need to Miss 14
consecutive elections including
Municipal State primary presidential
primary and general election for six
years that's what the bill has agreed to
in the committee of conference would
do now the purpose of this bill in my
view is to
reduce the possibility the likelihood of
someone attempting to take advantage
systematic way let's say of a 10-year
accumulation of names and addresses on
the checklist which are no longer
valid I see that as a
vulnerability and I think it's Our
obligation to address that vulnerability
with this bill because in considering
why we're doing this we have an election
law system in my mind the purpose of
this election election law system is to
assure that our governments all of them
have the consent of the government and
the way it our elections fulfill this
purpose is to make an accurate
assessment of public sentiment or the
will of the public the will of the
people
while ensuring also public trust and
confidence in that election system now
in terms of an accurate assessment I see
three
elements
first we have to ensure that all
qualified voters have the opportunity to
cast a ballot while also ensuring that
no no one who is unqualified to vote
gets that
opportunity and the others are obviously
secrecy of the ballot and an accurate
tabulation of the votes so this bill
focuses on the first of those elements
the equal obligation we have to ensure
all qualified voters get to cast a
ballot and no one who's unqualified gets
to do so and the reason that's important
is because every time an unqualified
someone is not qualified to vote cast a
ballot they damage the franchise of
everyone who is qualified to
vote and this is I think a
straightforward way to reduce the
likelihood of un people who are not
qualified to vote from getting to cast a
ballot so in
summary six-year look back 14 straight
elections someone didn't vote and we're
obligated to do this to ensure the value
of the franchise for those who are
qualified to vote so I ask you to press
the green button to concur with the
uh uh the committee of a conference
report thank you all very much for your
time a division has been requested
members take your seats this will be a
division
vote e
the motion before us is to adopt the
committee of competence report on 1369
this a division vote chair recognized
represent Mirad for parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill will confuse and anger lots of
citizens who are forced to defend their
right to vote for no
reason if I know that this bill will
create less accurate not more accurate
voting lists and if I know that this
bill is likely to disenfranchise lots of
Voters voters with loyalties to both
parties and Independence as well than
what I vote red to oppose this committee
report chair recognize represent quirley
for a parliamentary
inquir thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that we are obligated
to ensure that only qualified voters get
to cast a ballot while ensuring that all
qualified voters have that
opportunity and if I know that 10 years
between cleanups of the checklist is far
too long and generally results in too
large an accumulation of names and
addresses on that checklist which are no
longer valid voter names and
addresses and if I know that this bill
is adopted as a presented in the
committee of conference
report employs a six-year look back
every four years which means 14 straight
elections would have to be missed by
someone on the checklist before they are
removed but they then vote green to
adopt this Common Sense measure to help
ensure the confidence and Trust of our
voters and the validity of our elections
thank you motion before us is to adopt
the committee conference report on House
Bill 136 9 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button of your opposer press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will tend to stay to the
vote 178 voting a 185 voting aay motion
committee
fails chair recog chair recognizes the
clerk for further Senate message
just a reminder that there's only one
vote if the motion either passes or
fails Mr Speaker the Senate has adopted
the recommendation of the committee of
conference to which is referred the
following titled Bill House Bill 1370
relative to eliminating voter
identification
exceptions represent Steven Smith mes
the
adoption Representative Steven Smith
moves the adoption option the committee
of conference report on House Bill
1376 chair recognized representative
Lane thank you Mr Speaker um I rise
today uh in opposition to the committee
of conference report to upend our
traditional New Hampshire
elections first I want to stress that
this is not simply a voter ID Bill we
already require that a voter provide
identification when registering to vote
if they do not and do not submit proof
up to 7 days after the election their
ballot is
denied this bill goes much much further
it requires that voters present proof of
citizenship in order to register to
vote if this law were to be adopted New
Hampshire will be the only state in the
nation to have this requirement so why
haven't other states required it well
there are several
reasons first only two documents can
prove that you are a citizen of the
United States if you're born here that's
your birth certificate or your passport
if you are a naturalized citizen the
only way that you can prove it is with
your passport or your National ation
papers many people have problems
obtaining these documents due to time
and
cost according to a survey of
Northeastern states only about 40% of
adults in the Northeast hold valid
unexpired passports passports cost about
$130 and they take up to eight weeks to
be
issued it takes up to six months and
about
$500 to obtain nationalization
papers many families simply do not have
the money to spend on a birth
certificate a passport or
nationalization papers onethird of New
Hampshire families have difficulty
meeting their normal household expenses
so cannot afford to spend money to
obtain these documents
most New Hampshire residents were born
in another state so must contact their
birth state for a birth
certificate it takes about three months
to get a birth certificate from
California or Illinois and about one
month to get one from
Texas and then of course there are the
associated fees with them that
vary because of the difficulty of
obtaining these requisite documents to
prove citizenship courts have
consistently ruled laws requiring proof
of citizenship to be
unconstitutional Kansas attempted to
require proof of citizenship in the two
years that was on the that law was on
the books over 30,000 people were
disenfranchised that's
12% of the voters who attempted to
register experts hired by the authors of
the bill admitted that over
99% of those disenfranchised voters were
US citizens the 10th Circuit Court
struck down the Kansas law and the US
Supreme Court refused to hear the case
which means it is now the law of the
land because the difficulty of obtaining
necessary documentation other states
understand that if a voter falsely
attests to citizenship they are guilty
of a felony in New Hampshire lying on a
citizenship affidavit is a class B
felony that can land you in jail for up
to seven years and result in a fee of up
to
$5,000 it would also lead to a lifetime
ban on
voting such a law could affect their
ability to obtain naturalization because
it shows a lack of good moral character
and they could be
deported with these potential penalties
Loom booming over them it is highly
unlikely that new that non-citizens will
misrepresent
citizenship the risks are just too high
a few years ago New Hampshire spent
about $5 million trying to defend
another law that limited a voter's right
to cast a ballot the now Infamous
sb3 this law is destined for the same
fate and we will once again incur
millions of legal fees simply because
because we refuse to believe the data or
learn from other states now let's turn
to the big Showcase of this law it's the
hotline which will replace
affidavits how is the hotline going to
work well that's a really good question
and it's one that not even our secretary
of state could answer he was unable to
answer questions definitively about the
hotline during the uh Committee of
conference including how many people
would staff the hotline or how long a
voter would be expected to wait while
their information is verified So in
theory you go to
vote you don't have the right documents
an election official is going to call
this H hotline that is staffed by an
employee of the Secretary of State's
office the AG's office and any other
state agencies yet to be determined this
group of government employees will
attempt to verify the voter's missing
information using databases of yet to be
identified State agencies and they're
not sure what is in those state agency
those state agency databases at least as
of the committee of conference when
asked whether this hotline could be in
effect on Election Day the secretary of
state has stated that it would be
difficult and if not implemented
correctly it will lead to long lines and
voters leaving the polling places
without voting
according to the Lebanon town clerk they
had
897 same day voter registrations during
the 2022 general election based on the
experience they can assume about 50% of
these voters might not have all the
required
documentation this means potentially
449 people will need verification tying
up three phone lines for 20 minutes per
call allowing 126 people to be processed
in 14 hours so we will have
automatically disenfranchised over 300
people other issues raised by Town
clerks point out that there is no real
way for the people on the other end of
the hotline to verify that the caller is
actually an election official they are
going to be calling from their personal
cell phones and what if the cell phone
service is lousy or
non-existent no reasons were given by
either the primary sponsor of this bill
or the Secretary of State and let me
remind you that this bill has never had
a public
hearing if a voter's information is not
verified by the hotline they get two and
a half days to go to court and the court
fee is
$280 and good luck getting the result
from any Court in two days so now we
have all these new procedures to
implement by September 10th over this
summer this means that in three months
time the secretary of state must design
the hotline system publish a new
election manual and then educate the
hundreds of local election officials
across the
state and our voters will need to
immediately begin obtaining all that
documentation that I talked about
earlier and even if they're diligent
many of them will not be able to do so
the governor has recently stated that
you never want to implement something
too fast and too drastic in a short
period of time that could potentially
cause any sort of
disruption into the system and then most
importantly when you have to pay to go
to court perhaps the most dangerous
thing about this bill is that the New
Hampshire will be at risk at losing our
Motor Voter exemption neither the
primary sponsor of this bill nor the
Secretary of State have spoken with the
Department of Justice to ask them to con
to confirm that this bill won't have us
lose our exemption so what happens if we
lose our exemption well we would have to
spend millions of dollars to immediately
get into compliance with Motor Voter and
we will incur more legal fees fighting
to protect our exemption second it will
allow thirdparty groups to register
voters it will not be the exclusive
province of Clerks anymore our exemption
requires that every voter must be able
to vote on Election Day this bill
undoubtedly jeopardizes our exemption
but we are still going forward without
fully examining this critical issue and
once we lose the exemption we can't get
it back the secretary of state has not
expressed support for this bill and the
New Hampshire City and Town's clerks
Association is vehemently opposed New
Hampshire elections are safe and secure
you don't have to take my ADI my word
for it secretary scanland Governor cunu
the special committee on voter
confidence your local election officials
they all agree
just also look at the data we are
risking the hard work we have done since
2020 to instill confidence in our
election system with a bill that rushes
to overhaul a tried and true system with
an untested theoretical system that has
serious constitutional problems exposes
us to losing Motor Voter exemption and
will create long line for voters and
turmo turmoil
for our local election officials this
bill will disrupt our upcoming elections
and disenchant disenfranchised voters if
you want to improve our system let's do
it thoughtfully and take the time to do
it right not like this support your
local clerks moderators and election
officials vote push with the red button
and against non against concurrence
thank you is a member yield to questions
uh no sir I don't member does not yield
Mr Mr Speaker I would like a roll call
vote
please chair recogniz representer
quy thank you Mr
Speaker the simple fact is for our
election system to be valid and function
properly
we are equally obligated to ensure that
all qualified voters can cast a ballot
and also that no unqualified no one who
is unqualified to vote gets the
opportunity a present system
where literally anyone in the world from
anywhere in the world from anywhere in
the country can walk into the polling
place in New Hampshire assert with no
supporting evidence whatsoever that they
are a qualified voter
uh by means of signing an
affidavit completely ignores the
necessity to ensure that only qualified
voters get to cast a
ballot this bill as passed by the house
did remove all exceptions to uh proving
your
qualification if you weren't already
registered to
vote the Senate's view was that we
should add a means of of supporting
people who were rejected by a moderator
and were grieved by that and wanted a
further opportunity to appeal their case
in real time on Election Day and
actually for three days afterwards as
well so they put into place a right to
judicial review essentially immediately
and an opportunity to get the support of
the State of New Hampshire in their
attempt to verify that they were
qualified to vote
I am asking that
you vote green to accept the committee
of conference
report and
therefore reinforce the validity of our
election system and support the trust
and confidence of our voters that they
know their votes are not being diluted
devalued by people who were not entitled
to and we are facing if there's a
vulnerability which we have then I
cannot calculate the the likelihood it
will be exploited but I know that it can
be and this is one way to reduce that
likelihood a great deal thank you very
much for what reason do a member rise to
make a motion of a higher priority State
your motion I move to table House Bill
1370 and I would ask for a division vote
it is a proper motion the motion before
us is the table House Bill
1376 the division has been asked for
members take your seats
get
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 1376 this a division vote chair
recognize representative whole for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill started with a title relative to
durable and temper proof election
containers for preserving
ballots if I know that this bill when
addressed by the body behind us came out
it50 but magically on the floor changed
and became autop pass and then Mr
Speaker if I know the body behind us
adopt an amendment that did not have a
public
hearing at all would I now vote to table
this such that this legislation could be
taken up in a future session as the idea
has a lot of Merit to to correct our
election laws thank you jerich andiz
Representative Steven Smith for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
all these topics were covered in public
hearings if I know you just sat through
the debate and those motions a little
spurred yes Mr Speaker if I would like
to move on and just have an up or down
vote on the conference report would I
press the red button the motion before
us is the table House Bill 1376 this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent peria
C represent Mirad
for all members present had an
opportunity to vote house attend to stay
the
vote 223 voting aay 141 voting aay House
Bill 1370 is right on the table chair
recogniz clerk for further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which was
referred the following title bill House
Bill 1380 relative to brew pub licenses
relative to insurance cost sharing
calculations and relative to receipt of
pharmaceutical rebates by insurers and
Pharmacy benefits
managers hunt moves we adopt the
committee conference report on House
Bill 1380 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I iOS a the eyes
have it and the committee conference
report is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk for further Senate message Mr
speaker the Senate URS of the house in
its Amendment to the
following entitled bill sent up from the
house relative to the
uh relative to prohibiting the disposal
of lithium ion batteries and solid waste
landfill facilities composting
facilities or
incinerators representative Aaron moves
that we adopt the committee confence
report on House Bill 1386
chair recognizes representative
hold thank you Mr
Speaker why would I stand up to oppose a
bill at the last possible moment
relative to lithium ion
batteries well Le let's let's take a
look at the at the legislative history
of this we have a law today that says no
wet cell batter batter shall be disposed
of in a solid waste landfill facility or
compos composting facility or
incinerator whether in or whether in an
a waste energy facility or otherwise
that's the current law don't throw car
batteries away pretty simple they leech
lots of sulfuric
acid we're changing that to no person
shall dispose of any wet cell batteries
today's law lithium ion batteries or
electronic devices or solid weight in
any waste Land Fill facility or
incinerator don't throw your iPad
away don't throw a lot of devices away
while I appreciate the intent of the
bill the problem is we're going to
penalize people per the current
statute what is the current penalty we
we asked that on Monday
night any person who violates any of the
provisions of this chapter meaning 149 M
or any rule adopted or order issued
under this chapter or any condition of a
permit issued under this CH chapter
shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor further down in that section
any person who violates any of the
provisions of this chapter or any rule
adopted or order issued under this
chapter or any condition or permit
issued under this chapter shall be
subject to a civil penalty not to exceed
$225,000 are we really sure that we want
our citizens charge $25,000 because they
happen to throw their iPad in the trash
after the battery was dead
I've spent 20 years working on lithium
batteries I probably know more than
anybody in this room relative to lithium
ion
technology Commercial Street in
Manchester in 2004 I was part of a
Development Group that burned down a lab
it wasn't our fault it was a supplier
out of um the automotive groups who had
sent over a prototype battery we plugged
it in the charge that night it was on
top of a carpeted floor
and lo and behold the device caught on
fire burning down a second floor lab on
Commercial Street in Manchester I'm very
familiar with lithium ion battery
fires I asked the sponsor I said what
chemistries are we talking about well
lithium ion I'm like are we talking
about lithium iron phosphate we talking
about lithium iron Cobalt lithium mag
magnesium which chemistry well we're
talking about lithium ion I appreciate
apprciate that we want to start
recycling these it's a great idea we
should all be good stewards of our
devices returning to them to recycling
facilities is in the best interest of
our environment creating penalties and
new statutes that penalize a kid for
throwing their toy toy away with civil
fines up to $25,000 is a bad idea I
would ask that you would oppose this
such that a a bill that addresses all of
these issues could be brought up in a in
a future session thank you
do you recognize representative
Aon thank you Mr
Speaker
colleagues this is a very important
bill and
merely prohibits the disposal of lithium
ion batteries and solid Wasteland fill
facilities composting facilities or
incinerators because we know we've had
Fire Marshals and we've had um uh
landfill facility uh supervisors and so
on come to our committee and
testify that the fires that these
lithium ion batteries can create are
horrific they are destructive they have
have damaged many uh some facil
facilities and we're just looking to um
eliminate that
problem this bill was heard in my
Committee in environment and agriculture
it was passed out of our committee
unanimously it passed through this house
unanimously when it got to the Senate
the Senate wanted to make some change an
amendment to the bill to just um change
some language that was
um typographical errors and whatnot and
when they did when they made their
Amendment their Amendment messed some
things up they ended up adding a section
which duplicated the definition of
computers and so what we had to do is
non-c concur with their uh Amendment and
so we found ourselves in a committee of
conference where the sponsor of the bill
brought an amendment to fix the problem
that the Senate amendment
created there was no uh in the original
Bill and also the
um uh the U the the Senate Amendment
there was no
changes
to the um the definition you
know the whe there was no change to
penalties or anything else that was
already established in statute
if we wish to change the penalties for
disposal incorrect disposal of uh any of
these items we can do that next session
but I think it's of utmost importance
that we at
least prohibit lithium ion batteries
from being disposed into the trash and
landfills which can be very
dangerous we uh the the um
there is in uh RSA 149 dmon 27 where we
talk about prohibited disposal um item
number three a says No Leaf or yard
waste shall be disposed of in a solid
waste landfill or incinerator including
any waste to energy facility any person
who violates this paragraph shall be
subject to the penalties and enforcement
provision of RSA
149-156 and in that provision is where
the penalties are identified we made no
changes with this bill to any of the
penalties we just merely said that um
lithium ion batteries should not be
disposed in landfills or incinerators or
these other
facilities so you know basically this is
a really good bill I think if we want to
come back and talk about um changing the
penalties at some further point in time
then that would be an appropriate thing
to do but I encourage you and I urge you
please to concur with this committee
conference report thank
you the motion before us is to adopt
adopt the committee of conference report
House Bill 1386 a division has been
requested members take your seats
Division
division e
the motion before us is to concur to
adopt the committee of convence report
on 1386 this a division
vote chair recognizes representative
vable for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that HB 1386 passed
the house and the other body on the
consent calendar after full hearings and
discussion with Dees and stakeholders
with not one person testifying in
opposition if I know that this bill
Banning the disposal of lithium ion
batteries is a top priority of the solid
waste industry to remove toxic waste
from the waste stream and to decrease
fire risk
municipalities the State Fire Marshall
and The Association of Fire Chiefs all
due to their extreme fire
risk if I know that many items of
electronic waste are already banned from
disposal and this updates the list and
the
definition and that the existing law
Banning electronic waste disposal along
with yard waste and wet cell
batteries uh will remain in place
regardless of whether this bill passes
and if I know this bill only adds
lithium ion batteries and some electric
long electronic waste to a longstanding
statute with longstanding related Dees
enforcement pres provision
that are applicable to virtually all
violation of Dees related laws and
finally if I know the committee of
conference report was necessary only to
correct a simple few drafting areas
errors the policy having been fully
vetted would I now pass the green button
and support this important safety
measure motion before us is to adopt the
committee conference report House Bill
1386 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose or press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
to represent
Bard represent I can't see thank you
represent borgan
all members present had the opportunity
to vote house attend to State the
vote 238 voting a 118 voting a committee
confer
is chair recognize the clerk forer a
senate
message Mr
Speaker the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following title bill house bill 14 00
relative to residential parking spaces
landlord tenant law unauthorized OCC
occupant evictions and Zoning procedures
concerning residential
housing representative Alexander M at we
adopt the committee of conference
report chair
recognizes representative Al
Ander thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker um
hp400 is a bunch of different bills
together um one is the compromise a
modest compromise on parking reform it
allows the free market to determine how
many parking spaces are needed for
multif family developments that language
or more stringent language pass the
house twice so this is moving towards um
more freedom for developers to for
multif family developments additionally
um we added a careful compromise
language between tenants rights
Advocates and housing providers that
allows an opportunity for a landlord um
to file a brief in court to evict
somebody who is squatting on their
property um in 48 hours without this
provision landlords would have to wait 9
to 11 weeks to evict somebody that is
squatting in their house so this is a a
protection for housing providers and
tenants rights Advocates support this
Vision as well we also added amended
language to allow municipalities to
create a tax cut for those that convert
office spaces to residential
developments this is crucial uh language
that would help uh alleviate the housing
crisis and this language sunsets in 10
years so this is a temporary solution
that will allow municipalities to do
more with the office spaces that are not
currently being used so with that I
encourage you to support the committee
of conference report thank
you chair recognized representative Len
turot thank you Mr
Speaker
hb14 is an Omnibus Bill that I'll call
The Good the Bad and the Ugly actually
it's the neutral the Bad and the Ugly
I'll start with the neutral and that's
sections 2 to7 of the bill which is the
anti- squatter legislation I'm not going
to speak to this as I think there are
positives and negatives there maybe
others plan to speak on that
let's start with the bad which is the
original Bill
1400 what this would do is amend current
par parking rsas from shall not require
more than two spaces residential spaces
down to 1.5 for some
scenarios interestingly a town such as
gtown already requires two spaces in
their zoning and the town of Salem and
some reaching projects uh have done
parking requirements from 1.3 to 1.7 the
Point here is that the M municipalities
working with their zoning regulations
and developers of the projects have
tailored the parking requirements to
meet their local needs this change to
the rsas is not needed or desired
municipalities configure parking
requirements without the top- down
mandates now we'll go to the
ugly the other body talked uh tacked on
S SP 538 which we call an omnus Bill
within this omnus bill that bill Bill we
killed in this body a little over a
month
ago it's back with some changes as a
reminder six section 8 and nine of that
was the community uh revitalization tax
relief now this was originally meant in
the irsa for the rehabilitation of
dilapidated buildings now the definition
would add office conversions Industrial
and Commercial Property
conversions it would permit the
governing body of the municipalities to
Grant tax relief for up to 30 years of
course anytime you grant property tax
relief on one property the ones in this
case that are being revitalized it would
be spread to all the other taxpayers in
that municipality this is
redistribution section 12 talks about
alternative adoption to zoning this
without question is the most honorous
piece of this uh s SP 538 if approved it
would allow the governing body to J
change the zoning in a m municipality at
will without the vote of the local
legisl body if and when adopted there is
no mechanism to retract the RSA language
as most other rsas similar to this do
allow you could you could go through and
figure out some uh scenarios here where
uh you vote this in the select board
changes or the the makeup of the
municipality citizens changes
politically doesn't matter what side of
the aisle you're on your own town your
town would then be stuck with allowing
the body to change the zoning at will
the other scenario of course would be uh
watching zoning being frequently
whipsawed um it's very expensive to to
do zoning changes and that uh you could
actually see zoning changes whips off
from one way to the other over a matter
of months the last one is alternative
Parking Solutions as drafted there are
four solutions that are proposed for
bypassing the current uh zoning
requirements for parking only one would
actually require parking for residents
of a development and that would be at a
lot off-site location of another
property owner when the property owner
was not using his spaces so what happens
when the property owner is using his
spaces where where do the cars go the
second would require ride share to
provide transportation for residents but
to where doesn't say other parking to
their workplace to shopping no answer to
these questions the third solution
public transport within a quarter of a
mile
again to wear and finally no parking
required again as long as there is quote
unquote walkability
infrastructure now what's interesting in
the same paragraph the committee of
conference added language that directly
conflicts with the next three paragraphs
in the bill I'm assuming they meant to
remove those three paragraphs but they
did not so now we have two
paragraphs in direct conflict with each
other in that uh particular
paragraph here's my personal
favorite section 10 of the original s SP
538 adds a new definition of qualifying
structure and in that new paragraph it
references RSA 79 e4d not important yet
here's the important part in the
committee of confence section
14 it repeals that same referenced
RSA so you're putting in a new
paragraph reference an RSA and then in
the end you kill the irsa makes no sense
but what you're seeing here is a prime
example of why legislators should not be
operating on the Fly meaning rushing
legislation without adequate time to
review and assess what is being
proposed so in in conclusion while there
is a piece regarding the antiqu anti-
squatters which may be helpful I'm
unaware that we have a problem in that
area and the other pieces of this
Omnibus Bill uh hp14 00 and H and SP
538 uh in my opinion are just too
honorous to allow the passage of this
legislation takes away local control
redistributes redistributes uh property
taxes to residential and other taxpayers
for the benefit of a few businesses
eliminates planning board involvement
giving selectman 100% of a control of
zoning at will takes away the voters
right to uh vote on approving zoning
changes think of that as losing checks
and balances
and again creates direct conflicts in
two separate areas of the bill so I
would ask that you vote read against the
motion to Concur and uh Mr Speaker I
have I think I've already requested a
roll call thank
you Jer Rec andiz REM is Dennis
Manion thank you Mr Speaker this bill
allows for expedited hearing process for
landlords to remove squatters from
rental units it also includes the same
expedited hearing process for
non-rental uh owners if you uh find
somebody squatting on your property when
I first saw this bill I had some
concerns about the 48h hour hearing
process for non-rental owners in my mind
that meant if you come home from
vacation and someone's in your house you
can't call the police and have them
removed you have to go through this 48
hour process through the court system
that's not the case uh and to ensure
that we put some language in the bill
that says nothing in this section shall
be construed to prevent the arrest and
prosecution of persons of a person for
pursuant to RSA 6351 or two which is
Criminal Tres pass a
burglary um so an example of where this
might happen if you have like a vacation
home you show up there somebody's in it
and they say they rented it from an
Airbnb and they have um documentation
that they did and this has happened
before in that case the police might be
leery of arresting somebody you should
be afforded that same right of the 48
hour process rather than waiting 6 to9
weeks which is what we told it would
take however we wanted to make sure that
this is not a tool for law enforcement
to circumvent arrest for probable cause
of burglary or Criminal Trespass nor is
it to be used as a defense for either
this language is a right afforded to a
non-rental owner to use as an option for
relief of a violation of burglary and
Criminal Trespass should any other
option be unsuccessful thank you Mr
Speaker
representative turot has requested a
roll call and that has been sufficiently
seconded so this will be a roll call
vote members take your
seats e
the motion before us is to adopt the
committee conference report on House
Bill
1400 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Len turot for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know there are
new zoning mandates regarding parking
parking that are not needed as they are
better handled at the local level if I
also know this bill would spread
property tax liabilities from a few to
the rest of the municipalities Property
Owners if I know the most onerous
provision would allow the governing body
rather than the citizens to change
zoning laws that
will and finally if I know there are two
blatant conflicting uh issues in the
language the COC failed to realize even
existed but I now press the red button
thank you Mr
Speaker Chair recogniz say
representative MC Williams for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know this bill
is a modest parking Reform Bill that is
a compromise between the House and
Senate position for 1.5 spaces for every
unit in multif family developments over
10 units and if I further know that this
bill bill is a compromise between tenant
Advocates and Lord landlord providers um
to help with housing on both sides of of
the coin finally if I know that this
bill upholds our current Criminal
Trespass statute and fairly carves out
civil versus criminal for squatting
concerns uh would I then press green yes
to pass this Fair compromised modest
parking Reform Bill thank you Mr Speaker
motion before us is to adopt the
committee ACC confence report on House
Bill 14 00 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house attend to stay to the
vote 205 voting a 14 49 voting a
committee of conference
report chair recognizes the clerk for a
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which was
referred the following title bill House
Bill 1573 relative to out of home
placements for
children Mark Pearson moves that we
accept the committee of conference
report are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay eyes have it committee conference
report is adopted the chair recognizes
the clerk for a further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the committee of conference
report to which is referred the
following titled Bill House Bill 1585
relative to the position of certified
Assisted Living medication Aid and
relative the state loan repayment
program for qualified nursing
professionals and making an
appropriation
therefore representative Wayne
McDonald's move we concur are you ready
for the question all those favor say I
pa
nay the eyes have it the committee of
conference report is adopted chair
recognize the clerk for a further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the comme
conference to which is referred the
following titled Bill House Bill 1596
requiring a disclosure of deceptive
artificial intelligence usage in in
political advertising represent St Smith
ad Representative Steven Smith moves
that we adopt the committee a conference
report are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
i n the eyes have it the committee of
conference report is adopted the care
recognizes a clerk for further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which was
referred the following titled Bill House
Bill 1600 establishing a committee to
study the aggregation of electric
customers by municipalities and
counties representative Rose moves we
adopt the committee of conference report
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay guys
have it Committee of conference report
is adopted the chair recogniz the clerk
for further Senate message Mr Speaker
the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following title bill House Bill 1616
relative to parental consent for student
participation in Medicaid to schools
program and establishing a pilot
Recruitment and Retention program within
the Department of Health and Human
Services
represent lad moves that we adopt the uh
Committee of conference report chair
recognizes representative
ccen thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
1616 creates an additional task that
duplicates the current process for
parental consent for services for
Medicaid to schools program some
Services provided to students identified
with disabilities are reimbursable
services to offset local school district
cost only services that are uh
considered medically necessary for the
student to benefit from their
educational program or setting are
eligible for reimbursement such as
occupational therapy Physical Therapy
some Psychological Services and they can
only be ordered by and and provided by a
licensed health professional so school
counselors special Educators tutors they
are not eligible Medicaid
providers so New Hampshire special
education procedural safeguards handbook
devotes four pages of parental consent
processes that must be followed for any
Services provided to a student so quote
the school district must request
parental consent in writing for a
special education and Rel services to be
provided to a child with a
disability as well as for other
activities that are part of the
specialed process so the parent has up
to 14 days to respond in
writing so parental consent means you
have been fully informed of all
information relevant to the activity you
understand and agree in writing to the
carrying out of the activity you
understand that the the granting of
consent is voluntary and you may revoke
it at any time this mandatory process
creates transparency and parental rights
and in protection for parent involvement
thus it negates the need for House Bill
1616 any Services can also be refused
with parental
signatures Federal reimbursement dollars
for eligible Services help to offset
local cost that is generally borne by
the local property taxpayer please vote
no on adopting this unnecessary
Committee of conference
report representative Lon recognized to
speak thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
two years ago a bill came through the
Health and Human Services committee so
that parents would need to consent to
medical treatment in schools that is
what this bill amends this is not a bill
that's limited to special education in
the schools however this has to deal
with everything between a scraped knee
vaccination clinics and even more
invasive procedures that may be
happening inside
schools this is an important bill
because initially when this bill was
passed we had parents getting a form
that said either you consent to
everything we want to do medically with
your child or we won't give them an ice
pack we had many many parents who would
not fill out that form as either
everything or nothing and they wrote in
the details this is a simple Common
Sense way to make sure that the parent
will agree to perhaps have them help
monitor their child's diabetes or help
them monitor some other other areas and
also to be informed if their child is at
a concussion in school and make sure
that they have to understand this this
is simple common sense and deals with
every student not just special education
so in order to keep parents a critical
part of the health of their children I
ask that you press the green button and
support this bill and Mr Speaker I ask
for a roll
call the questions on the adoption of
the conference report on House Bill 1616
representative Lyon requests a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded it is this
will be a roll call vote members take
your
seats
e
e e
the questions on the adoption of the
conference report on House Bill
1616 representative Bal Bon is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this legislation
has nothing to do with the delivery of
services and parents already must give
consent for for any changes to an i AP
as well as annual permission to build
the Medicaid to schools
program and I know that requiring
additional written consent for Medicaid
billing is not required by federal
statute and will only disrupt medic
reimbursement to schools thus increasing
costs to local school districts and
taxpayers and finally if I know that the
pilot Recruitment and Retention program
was approved earlier in HB
1236 so that the spill is both fiscally
irresponsible and unnecessary would I
now press the red button to vote against
the committee of conference report to be
fiscally responsible to New Hampshire
taxpayers representative Lads recognized
for parliamentary
in thank you Mr Speaker if I believe
parent consent and approval is necessary
when schools bill for new or additional
Medicaid reimbursement Services Beyond
those previously approved by the parent
and if I also know an additional layer
of protections for taxpayers and the
child come from this bill and if I
lastly know the bill as amended will
provide needed grant funding support to
proactively address vacancy rates Acuity
care and Reliance on contractor sta
staff at the sonunu Youth Services
Center and at the hamsten hospital
treatment
facility would I then support hb1 1616
as amended by pressing the green
button the questions on the adoption of
the conference report on House Bill 1616
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
all
representative
Griffin representative
Griffin have all members pres had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 173 and the affirmative 179 on
negative motion f
CH recognize the clerk for our Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate is adopted
the recommendation of the committee of
conference to which is referred the
following title bill House Bill 1622
relative to administrative rulemaking
and license renewals by the office of
professional lure and certification and
this was a consent calendar bill
representative Maguire moves the
adoption representative McGuire moves
the adoption of the committee of
conference report are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay eyes have it and the
committee of conference report is
adopted chair recognize the clerk for
further Senate message Mr Speaker the
Senate has adopted the recommendation of
the committee of conference on the
following title bill House Bill 1623
relative to involuntary retirement or
decommissioning of electricity
generators represent
representative v m adoption of Committee
of conference report are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those oppos nay the eyes have it and
committee conference report is adopted
chair recogniz the clerk for a further
Senate message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which was
referred the following en titled Bill
House Bill
1633 relative to the legalization and
regulation of cannabis and making
Appropriations therefore
represent hunt
moves adopting Committee of conference
report on
1633 the house will be in order
chair chair recognizes
chair recogniz representative Jared
Sullivan thank you Mr
Speaker I guess we're back at this again
two weeks
later two weeks ago today I stood here
and argued against concurring on 16 1633
as amended by the Senate I must admit
1633 is proving to be a pretty stubborn
bill that refuses to Die the perplexing
thing about the immortality of this bill
is that literally nobody in this body
likes this
bill two weeks ago the prime advocate
for this Bill said and I quote the
Senate made this bill the ugliest most
government intrusive most over
and he was right then and that statement
remains true
today the thing is the committee of
conference did little to address the
ugliness of
1633 1633 Remains the most intrusive big
government marijuana program proposed
anywhere in the country one that ignores
free market principles will stifle
innovation in an emerging industry and
tie future generations of granite saders
to an inferior model
indefinitely the ranking House member oh
sorry the ranking house Democrat on the
Commerce Committee the respectable
representative from Bartlett a man I
truly a woman I truly uh agree with and
enjoy working with said in closing
comments last week on the committee of
conference I want to make it clear I am
signing off on this with a lot of angst
those are not the words of somebody who
is confident in their
position now the member from ringe the
chairman of my committee a man I also
greatly respect for his deep knowledge
he's our our official historian for our
committee and his grace in handling
disagreements within our committee
maintains The View that we should pass
this deeply flawed Bill ugly bill
because we can fix it later while I
trust his intentions I really do and I
do respect him I disagree with his
thinking for two reasons first upon
signing the Liquor Commission will
immediately receive $8 million to start
developing rules and infrastructure to
regulate this new government-run
cannabis industry does anyone in here
actually believe that we will be able to
re reel in a newly empowered government
bureaucracy after they've spent millions
of dollars does anyone honestly believe
it will be easy to pull back power from
an unelected agency once they have it
two the logic that we can fix something
next year is
counterintuitive because if next year we
have the ab ility to pass a new bill to
fix this terrible one than we should
just pass a good bill next year one that
decriminalizes starting in 2025 instead
of 2026 which is the current
timeline I like many in this room
seriously want to legalize cannabis
sales in New Hampshire but the fact is
despite the the member the member will
suspend there's not many of you left in
the room but yet it's louder than it
normally is if you need to have a
conversation that's what the back room
is for member may continue I like many
in this room seriously want to legalize
cannabis sales in New Hampshire but the
fact is despite the recent tweaks this
remains a terrible Bill the same
terrible Bill we defeated two weeks ago
one that massively increases the size of
government by allowing it to take over
an entirely new industry and opens the
door for the possibility of rampant
corruption and coronis as the
well-connected vibe for an extremely
limited number of licenses
in closing government is never more
dangerous than when our desire to have
it help us blinds us from its great
power to harm us let's not let us not be
blind in this moment thank
you jerck and I representative
Lon thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise today in support of house bill
1633 while my ideal model looks
different I have this conference report
has my full support we have the
opportunity today to make history as a
25th state to legalize cannabis which
may fit tip Federal action there's
already discussion about descheduling
and there's disc there's discussion
federally about changing the status of
of cannabis within the country imagine
if your vote today led to that change in
federal policy where it no longer was
ferally prohibited more importantly
though today we have the chance to get
the ball rolling in New Hampshire most
of this bill won't go into effect until
2026 which gives us more time to fight
about some of the challenges and some of
the concerns we have about this bill I
plan to be back in this room working on
policy next year assuming that Dairy
voters give me a third term in the house
by the time we meet again in this
chamber the people making that the
Liquor Commission will have started the
rules process and will know if we need
to make changes in order to better guide
that process if the Control Commission
has is a roadblock we will know if there
are other problems we will know and we
will have a legislative season that we
can do something about it and make the
changes because it is easier to make
changes than to start something new and
upon passage people making normaliz
purchases out of state will face a
violation instead of a misdemeanor yes
that's right criminalization will go up
to 1 ounce which is what the purchase
limits are in a lot of surrounding
states which means that perhaps there'll
be fewer than a thousand people arrested
for possession next year like were in
2023 in New Hampshire so please join me
in taking a step forward to make New
Hampshire EST state where we can start
having Frank discussions about the risks
of cannabis instead of just pretending
that making it illegal makes all the
problems go away please vote green and
let's move New Hampshire forward thank
you
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion Mr Speaker your motion I
have motion to table HB
1633 that is a proper motion the motion
before us is a table House Bill
1633 roll call has been requested is
that sufficient is that sufficiently
seconded you need to be in your
seats it's not sufficiently seconded
this will be a division
vote
e e
members take your seats
the the
motion the mo house will be in
order sit down the motion before us is
to table House Bill
1633 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Simon for for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that eight people are signed
up to speak on this bill and Mr Speaker
if I know the house probably already has
a position and we can determine now
whether or not we want this legislation
to move forward without having to listen
to everybody speak um would I now press
the green button and uh table hb1 1633
thank you chair recognize your
representative hunt for a parliamentary
inquiry okay Mr
Speaker if you all want to leave least
go forward and have a good debate and
maybe actually pass it which would be a
miracle if I believe this is the moment
to send the message that we can pass
this bill would I now vote Yes excuse me
no okay please vote no on the tabling
motion the motion before this is the
table House Bill
1633 this is going to be a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
for
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote household attendance stay to the
vote 17 house will be in
order 178 voting a 173 voting a house
bill 1633 is laid on the
table representative Beth Richard
declared a conflict and did not
participate
the house recognize the clerk for a
further Senate
message Mr Speaker the Senate has
adopted the recommendation of the
committee of conference to which was
referred the following entitled Bill
House Bill 1665 relative to student
eligibility for Education Freedom
accounts and the scholarship
organization's cost of administering the
program extending phase out grants for
Education Freedom accounts and revising
the definitions of average daily
membership and attendance and average
daily membership in
Residence representative lad moves we
adopted conference report chair
recognized representative
Guthrie thank you Mr Speaker it looks
like we all want to go home so I'll be
as brief as I can this bill is pretty
straightforward it uh changes from 400%
of the federal property guidelines to
425 per of the federal property
guidelines in the EFA program now
1665 has an FM on it that means it's
cost some money so I think uh that uh
one of the concerns but in my case I I
submit to you that although I I support
any family who wants to go outside the
public school environment and educate
their children I think that's that's
fine if they're unhappy with our system
however I have difficulty having the
state funding that
system I have having said that I ask
that you concur on House Bill
1665 a bill that would increase the
funding of this program my message to
you is our responsibility is the funding
of our own local school
system and as a former school committee
I ask you to please join me and push the
red button to non-c concur I ask for a
roll call thank you chair recognize
repres
luno thank you Mr
Speaker in three years what have we
learned about the education Freedom
account
program we've learned more than 90 95%
of EFA kids were already in private or
religious schools or in home schools
before the EF Pro EFA program ever
existed and we've learned fewer than 5%
of EFA students left their public
schools because of this program we've
learned the Department of Education
isn't interested in fraud prevention and
has even obstructed State Auditors from
investigating fraud we've learned that
at least one EFA vendor has been
classified by as a hate group and we've
learned that even some
proponents of the tax Fair funded EFA
program are wincing at the idea of
expanding eligibility to families
earning more than1 132,000
A Year Without at least an annual income
recertification
requirement I'm sure you'll hear about
how other parts of this report improve
the program but it's not enough to
overcome all this if you like how wildly
successful this taxpayer funded giveaway
is now please vote no on the conference
committee report thank
you chair recognized representative lad
thank you very much Mr
Speaker this program is
working uh I'd like to look at some of
the changes which have occurred as a
result of our putting the EFA program
into work here several years back we are
now providing life-changing experiences
for many children which had unsuccessful
experiences in the rigor education
system and that was occurring years
before when we had bullying going on uh
stud students attending schools for the
academic achievement in certain areas
was at the bottom of the achievement
scale so we have made some compromises
in this bill dealing with the EFA and
the committee of conference had to sit
down and we went through three separate
we had a break break break come back on
three different days to arrive where we
are the amendment achieved a compromise
in terms of
Eligibility a family of four the medium
family income is now going from 350%
to
425 this house had it passed earlier
this year 500% if you look at that we've
split the difference we're halfway
between 350 and
500 I'd like to look at some of the
folks which are going to be now eligible
and that's important we have a middle
class in this state and due to inflation
real income not going the way it should
be and debt piling up we have some
figures I'd like to share with you here
a single nurse with one schoolage child
earning
$83,400
previously was not eligible now with
this bill they will be eligible a
married couple one working in a
restaurant as an employee a school
teacher the other with one child earning
a with one child a comb with a combined
income of
$13,810 that family will now be
eligible a family of three two parents
working a combined three jobs and
earning
$105,000 was not eligible under 350 but
will be now under
425 we are going to get more kids
involved and this opens the door up to
60% of students in this state and that
is critical and important
this adjustment opens the doors to many
other middle-income New Hampshire
families secondly what this bill
does it drops the administrative costs
of the EFA program from 10% of the
received monies used for administration
now to 8% the actual figure is less than
8% but I want to make a note that in
past when the administrative cost been
less than that 10% that money is turned
around to use for students who are
applying for the EFA program it's used
for students not for administration I'm
sure the director over there the
scholarship organization will do the
same thing moving
forward we also have a phaseout grants
program which is within this bill and
it's being extended from 2026 another
three years
2029 and lastly I want to touch upon the
issue that less than 3% of New Hampshire
students participate in the EA program
3% of about 164,000 kids were hammering
away at those
4,875 kids taking advantage of this
program there are many programs with
students fit best in and this is one
it's not the only program we have
Alternative forms of Education we have
Charter Schools we have rigor Public
Schools I for one when my student was
not successful I spoke about earlier
today took my student student and
enrolled them in the Warren Village
School where speech th Services were
provided properly so in conclusion the
hope of many for a successful 2025
school year is a decision that we will
make today and I encourage all to press
the green button thank you very
much presentive Guthrie has requested a
roll calls that's officially
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
clear
the motion before us is to adopt the
committee of conference report in 1665
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Miler for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the education
Freedom account program was initiated
and AD dedicated as a poverty program to
assist families earning less than 350%
of the poverty level and that the
current proposed
changes basically change the intent of
the program by increasing the level to
425 for a family earning
$133,000 a
year if I know that unlike other state
budgeted programs
the EFA is has little accountability and
oversight for a $0 million program with
the majority of the house rejecting any
attempt to provide appropriate guard
rails on the management of the
program if I know that of the 160,000
public school students only
5% have left the public schools and that
the majority of the EFA funds are being
directed to students who are currently
in private or religious
schools if I know that the origin of the
EFA program was initiated without a
proper public hearing and that the
public interest surveys object to having
public tax dollars paying for Religious
Education and finally Mr Speaker if I
believe that the EFA Advocates
ultimately want this program to
eventually become a universal program
available to All Families regardless of
their income level to access public tax
dollars and further drain needed tax
dollars away from the overwhelmingly
publicly supported public education
would I now reject House Bill
1665 and stop the expansion of the EFA
voucher program to the for 125% level by
pressing the red button thank you Mr
Speaker Jer recogize representative lad
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know I
would welcome your support for Universal
EFA
program and if I know this bill
increases the household income
eligibility cap for Education Freedom
accounts from 350 to 425 of the federal
poverty guidelines which is close to
medium income in the state if I believe
the by expanding the eligibility level
offers a lifechanging increase for many
middle-income New Hampshire families who
are drowning and trapped under high
inflationary expenses and debt if I
further know that there are many
families seeking the right educational
fit who will realize hope through this
educational option and lastly would I
then support middle-income children and
families with the benefits of school
choice by pressing the green button
thank you very much Mr Speaker the
motion before us is
to adopt the committee of confence
report on House Bill 1665 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative D Silvestro
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will tend to state of the
vote 168 voting yay 185 voting a
committee of conference report fails
[Music]
for what reason does member Rise um for
a motion State your motion remove House
Bill 1633 from the
table and I request a roll call vote
okay
the mo representative Crow has asked for
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote on
removing 1633 from the table
clear
also be in
order the motion before us is to remove
House Bill 1633 from the table this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative Prout for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know the roll
call on placing this bill on the table
failed due not enough people in the
room and if I know that this is an
important policy that our constituents
deserve to know where we stand on with
by a roll call vote and that this vote
will be that
vote and if I know that this policy is
an important one that is right for New
Hampshire and will be right will be
watched by many people and will be a
historic event of being the 25th state
if we pass it would I now press the
green button to remove it from the
table the motion before us is to remove
House Bill 1633 from the table this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
never
mind represent Canon
all members present had an opportunity
to vote also attend to stay to the
vote 162 voting aay 189 voting a the
motion
failed chair recognizes the clerk for a
senate message Mr Speaker the last
Senate
message the Senate has adopted the
recommendation of the committee of
conference to which was referred the
following titled Bill House Bill
2024 relative to the State 10year
Transportation ation Improvement plan
relative to adding a speed limit of 45
mph on Rural highways relative to
disability pensions for Public Safety
employees who are victims of violence
and making a capital appropriation of
the Department of Corrections toward the
replacement of the New Hampshire state
prison for
men represent mccon moves we adopt the
committee of conference report are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I
iose
nay the eyes have committee conference
report is adopted
for what reason does a member rise Mr
Speaker I'd like to request the remarks
from HB 1665 be recorded in the
permanent journal without
objection then we'll put it to a vote
objection has been
given okay
the house will be in
order the question is to print the
remarks in the per
of
1675 1665 I'm sorry are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
those
opposed guys have it will be
printed okay the chair recogniz the
chair recognizes a member from Auburn
representative Osburn for a motion to
adjourn from the early session you need
to stay in your
seats resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time when the house
adjourns today at be to meet at the call
of the
chair are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I close nay the
eyes have a motion is adopted chair
recognizes the clerk for announcements
thank you Mr Speaker I have a couple of
announcements a couple on behalf of the
speaker uh as many of you know we have
several statutory uh committees or
statutory commissions that may be
enacted into law if you are interested
in serving on any of those committees or
commissions please contact the speaker
office once those have been signed into
law if after today you are interested in
having a bill uh signing ceremony in the
governor's office please contact the
governor's office uh for said um request
additionally we do have a few requests
for unanimous consents including
Memorial remarks coming up so please if
you have to exit please do so quietly
and lastly uh for those of you that wore
sear sucker today if you'd like to have
a picture up front please stick around
after thank you thank
you chair recognizes representative
early for uh Memorial
remarks thank you Mr Speaker and I'd
like the Hudson delegation to join me
please can the members stay in your
seats this is a memorial remarks
thank you Mr Speaker a few hours
ago uh The Honorable Lynn oer of Hudson
announced the passing of her husband
Russ many of us have served with
Lieutenant Colonel Ross oer over the
years he was on Ways and Means for much
of his uh second Public Service life
Russ was a 23y old veteran of the uh
United States Air Force with over 600
hours of combat uh service in Vietnam he
also earned a silver star for his
pivotal role in The santoy Raid his air
medals had 19 19 Oakleaf clusters Russ
was a very strict math teacher over at
Alver high school and uh served here in
the house on uh Science and Technology
he was the chair of the veterans and he
served in ways and means
in town his BMW was always uh seen at
the various events around town he and
his wife
were well she still is an integral part
of the town after a brief fight with uh
esophageal cancer Russ left this world
on 610 but his death was only announced
today he left a large family and his
wife of 53 years
I won't miss this uh tall distinguished
gentleman in his brown
suit and cherish his
memory can we all rise for a moment of
silence for rest over
thank you Mr Speaker Mr speaker thank
you four reason to member rise Mr
Speaker I would move that the remarks in
memory of Representative Russ sober be
printed in the permanent journal and
that the uh condolences of the house be
extended to The Honorable Lynn Ober
without
objection here recognized representative
margerie Smith we've got a few more if
you just sit in your seats for a few
minutes these are people that won't be
with us next session so representative
Smith thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I look around and I
realize that about
onethird of those of us who are in the
room will not be back
next term that's the usual
turnover whether it's more or less I
don't know some of those who will leave
are people who have been our colleagues
and who we have worked with some of
those who will leave have become our
closest friends and we will very much
miss them but perhaps actually get to
see them in another
environment Mr Speaker I have just
signed up for my 14th time and I have
never asked for unanimous consent before
because I could not imagine that anyone
would choose to stay here just to hear
me
speak and today I am asking you to do
that because I am not speaking about
myself I am speaking about a member of
this body who has has done what no one
has done before and possibly no one else
will do in the future I'm speaking about
our friend and our colleague Steve
[Music]
[Applause]
Sheriff Steve came to this body first
when he was I think a fourth grader and
he walked he walked into this room and
thought it was something that was going
to mean everything to
him he then went through his
schooling he fought in a war for all of
us he then went and worked for the
Federal
Marshals and eventually he came came
back to a place that he has
loved he has served on any number of
committies he has been the minority
leader he has been the majority leader
he has been as you saw today the most
able speaker and he has because of the
courtesy of the incumbent speaker also
been in the speaker am
Meritus um those are positions that no
one else in the history of this
legislature has
accomplished if you are to leave here
today and walk past the State Library
you will see a statute of John Wan a
former governor of the state and you
might see sitting on the bench next to
to win and Steve
shirtliff who goes to sit
there and think about what wian did
under the most
unbelievably difficult
circumstances there had been an
ambassador to Great
Britain just before the start of World
War
II who really was not terribly
uncomfortable with what was happening in
Germany
and I think many of you know who he who
he was he subsequently had a son who
grew up to be president of the United
States wet knew that there was a problem
and he worked unbelievably hard to make
sure that the United States played the
role that it should play in terms of
fighting
for democracy in something that we in
this body and across the country have
always held
dear that was the behavior that has
shaped Steve
Sheriff's life I don't agree with Steve
on everything I just don't really know
anybody who I've agreed with on
everything but Steve stands out as
someone who recognized that there is n
no such thing as people on one side of
the aisle or the other that there's no
such thing as people who deserve to be
respected as against those who do not
deserve to be respected Steve provided a
model for us that if we can live up to
it next term and the term after and the
term after that forever in the future we
will do very well
in this body to preserve the core values
that we do in fact all share and I hope
you will join me today in Wishing Steve
well as he goes on to play a different
role in the public sector and continuing
to behave in a way that we all would
admire thank you very much
[Applause]
Ste Steve just told me to hit the
Gabel for what reason does a member eyes
to make a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion Mr Speaker as
a police academy graduate along with
representative search Liff Way Back in
1970 I would urge the remarks of the
prior speaker be put in the permanent
Journal definitely without
opposition our chair recognized Maria
Perez
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
members of the House for allowing me to
speak today first of all I want to take
a minute to say thank you to my family
um my family for the last 20 years had
made a lot of sacrifices for me to be
here for me to have a seat in this house
I would like to say thank thank you
thank you so much from the bottom of my
heart especially my daughter my son and
my
grandson I sacrifice a lot of time to be
here and not spending with my
family I sacrify many things but I'm
proud to be here it's been the hottest
probably two years of my life me taken
the decision to be independent it was
the hardest decision ever but it was
needed it was needed because my voice it
needs to be
here by independent voters I don't care
who you are I don't care if you're a
Democrat or Republican I see you as a
person and many of you has been showing
me respect from both side of the AIO I
build relationship with a lot of
Republicans and I will I will say thank
you thank you for showing me respect may
we may not agree with a lot of things
things but I can say that it's been my
pleasure and my honor to work with a lot
of you and for many of you show me the
sky is of the
limit as an
immigrant I never thought I was going to
be SE in this house I never thought I
was going to have a seat in this house
and it's been the orner of my
life thank you Catherine thank you
Junior thanks to my my husband Louis
he's been the rock star our marriage is
not perfect I can tell you that but he's
been there and his hottest night of my
life he's been there to support me when
I feel like I have no no way to get
out I would like to say thank you too to
the elected officials of Mexico for
allowing me and give me the opportunity
I just came back from Mexico I was one
of the international elected officials
invited to the
elections one at a one in a lifetime two
females running for president it was my
honor to be in Mexico to
witness the democracy is not there
people lose in the life just to have the
right to vote I witnessed I saw the news
I was in the middle of people getting
killed 28 candidates got
killed one was elected the day of the
election and he was celebrating his
election winner when he got
killed that gave me a different
perspective what democracy means if we
complain about our elections here let me
tell you we have it
easy what I saw there is
horrible thank you so much like I say
thank you so much for the opportunity to
be here I would like to take a minute
too to say thank you to the Aran MAA
family of Waka Mexico they welcome me to
their
house I was afraid to what happened to
me but I want to make sure that I
witness everything that was happening in
Mexico because I want to bring that
information to you guys and I will make
a report so you guys can see that we
have it easy here and I'm going to say
thank you in Spanish because the deserve
for me told them in Spanish because
they're probably going to watch this
video
um for
thank you very
[Applause]
much chair recognized representative Neo
David chair recognized representative
David
Nagel uh thank you Mr Speaker and I
would like to thank the clerk for his
patience with me this is my third try at
doing this um I also would like to thank
honorary speaker am Meredith shirtliff
who I tried to tell you in the bathroom
that you were actually inspiration for
what I'm about to say so um I thought
maybe the bathroom wasn't the right
place to do that besides he was
busy every address needs a a
title mine's attribute to fear and I
want to tell you about somebody you've
never met but I hope he will inspire you
as much as he's inspired me um I think
at times I'm the the luckiest man in the
entire world and no I never played for
the New York Yankees and no I don't have
ALS but I've been very fortunate I some
of you older folks I hope you know that
reference but anyways Lou gar anyways so
anyways I I I've lived my childhood
dream my entire life since I was in
fourth grade I stood up for somebody who
was being abused by other people and I
found that like so empowering that I
wanted that to be the what I did the
rest of my life and in doing so I was
living up to my mom my mom was disabled
but somehow she was a real life Good
Samaritan who always put the needs of
everybody else above her own and I
always wanted to be like
her un like my mom though I'm able and
I'm able to travel the world and do all
sorts of things and I've been able to
meet all sorts of amazing wonderful
people and in one of my travels when I
was uh I met this gentleman named John
Bell who you have not met um John um I
met in a strange way he was sitting
right there when I gave my book launch
at the center for practical bioethics in
Kansas City that's a talk for another
day what the center does but they do
amazing bioethical work and I've been am
really lucky to been part of them for
the last 15 years and when I did my book
launch that's the only place that I
wanted to do it so um when I got there
you don't need to know what my book is
about but what I did do was look at a
complex social problem that of how
poorly we manage pain and I looked at
all the different institutions in our
culture that deal with that and using
the Good Samaritan as my guide what do
you say you're going to do for people in
need what do you actually do what's the
gap between and how do we bridge that
through creative public policy in the
middle of that I develop what I call the
hypocrite scale if you do what you say
you're going to do and you help that
person in need you're a hero maybe even
a saint if you don't do it then you're a
hypocrite and if you turn around and
actually abuse the person in need you're
a coward and when I present my book talk
I say usually I'm kind of in the
hypocrite range on that scale and so as
I'm giving my talk there's this guy in
the front row and I'm you know I don't
know about how when you guys give talks
but I always seem to focus on one person
and I focused on John and I think the
reason why was cuz he looked like he
wasn't listening to a word I was saying
and and it didn't like I was like really
you know getting in or anything like
that and then finally you know the talk
comes to an end and we do discussion and
so the first person to stand up was John
and I found out that John always looks
that way and that he heard everything I
said he'd actually even read my book and
he wanted to share a story so John um is
africanamerican um he's lived with pain
his whole life he has sickle cell anemia
um sickle cell disease creates periods
of what we call crisis where you can get
anywhere from moderate to severe
pain when your Pain's really bad you go
to the ER and that's what John did one
day and when he went there he was so
disenchanted with how the people treated
him like he wasn't worthy like his
self-esteem his Integrity wasn't worthy
of the guy's effort so needless to say
that really didn't sit very well one
thing I didn't tell you is John works
for the center as a citizen Advocate
meaning he advocates for the rights of
people who are disabled on his own time
no pay nothing so three weeks later
John's back at the hospital advocating
for somebody and he gets on the elevator
to go up to the third floor and he
pushes the button you know how the doors
are shut and an arm comes right through
like that well an arm came through and
John said that was the doctor that
treated me in the emergency room and the
minute the doctor looked at him he kind
of got like a look like of
recognition and John looked at him and
think about you have that opportunity
this is a Gibbs NCIS elevator moment
what would you say to him and I you know
when John then said he goes to me this
was a teaching moment and I looked at
him and I said do you know who I am and
the doctor said yes and he goes listen
he goes when I need you there for me I
need you to be there but I don't need
you right now but I when I need you I
need you to be there so then I asked
John why did you do that why didn't you
just give him a piece of your mind
because a lot of people would have done
that and John
said if I had done that I would have
lost an opportunity to teach this doctor
that he made a mistake and that's how he
should treat other
people so you know last I checked I'm
white he's black there's certain things
you don't say on your first meeting and
I was not comfortable John and I got to
be really good friends and a couple
years later I finally asked him the
question I really wanted to ask on the
day one he says do you think they
treated you that way because you're
black and and I we know that black males
especially are are stigmatized in the
Health Care system did they treat you
that way because you were in pain
because we know people in pain are
stigmatized and he didn't even hesitate
to answer he goes no the answer is fear
and I said you know I this is my
Freudian Jim Freudian instead of an I
just said fear he goes yeah fear of the
ramifications of doing the right thing
and immediately when he said that I knew
what he was talking about I don't know
how many times I've stood up for
somebody and had to you know get take a
lot of grief for doing it every time I
write an opioid prescription half the
planet wants to tell me I'm doing the
wrong thing and so I knew what he was
talking about but then that brought me
to hear I was not doing doing well not
long ago I was like wondering why am I
here what am I doing I'm making
decisions pushing buttons that I don't
agree with and the whole time I'm
thinking well what would John say and so
then you
know I talked to a whole bunch of people
here and everybody said the three things
that are most important when you make a
decision
are
conscience constituents and party in
that order and and then I looked at one
person I said if that's the case then
why aren't I doing that and so I decided
I needed to go back to Kansas City to
find home and I get back there there was
a dinner and I go to the dinner and I
see my friend Cindy and I go how's John
and she said John's gone he died three
months before and he was
gone and I'm
like not sure what to say
so in 4 minutes I went went through kuer
Ross's five stages of grieving and came
to equilibrium and I finally realized
John the Gospel of John the word became
flesh and he lived Among Us and I
realize that we live on not in who we
are now but in what we do in word and
deed and that was the message that I
took home and when I came back here all
the sudden it was like somebody took a
yoke off my shoulders and all of the
sudden I was willing to say what I felt
I needed to say push the buttons that I
felt that I needed to put push and it
was the best day in my life and so what
I hope for you is that John can be an
inspiration to you and also if you pray
could you please say a prayer for him so
that he finds his home where where I
hope we all find our home someday thank
[Applause]
you shair recogniz represent
Rosner good afternoon it's an honor to
talk to the most patient of us
here um these are going to be short
remarks um honoring pride month I
welcome anybody who is of the LGBT
community or in support if they want to
stand with me they are welcome to if you
would like to keep sitting you're
invited to if you're ready to go home
the doors are that
way pride month celebrated every June
honors the lgbtq community's resilience
diversity and
contributions its Origins Trace back to
the 1969 ston wall riots in New York
City where lgbtq individuals resisted
police brutality and discrimination
sparking a broader movement for equal
rights a complete account of the
Stonewall uprisings has been lost to
time today it serves as a powerful
symbol of resistance against queerphobia
and police brutality in the in our
modern American
history pride month not only
commemorates the Stonewall Uprising
Uprising but also serves as a reminder
of the ongoing struggle for acceptance
and equality it is a time for
celebration reflection and advocacy
highlighting the importance of
visibility and solidarity in achieving a
more inclusive Society to those who have
taken the time to stand with us to speak
out and to show you your support in
countless ways including the many
colorful outfits and accessories I have
seen today thank you your actions both
big and small make a profound Difference
by being visible and vocal you help
create a more inclusive and accepting
world
your allyship strengthens our resolve
and inspires us to continue striving for
equality and justice for all together we
are building a future where everyone can
live openly and ath and authentically we
see you and we honor you and we thank
you it's important to remember that
being an ally to the lgbtq community
involves actively supporting and
standing up for our rights and dignity
it doesn't require you to be an an
expert in fact in many ways it denotes
that you must recognize that you are not
this can start with educating oneself
about our unique life challenges
listening to lgbtq plus voices about our
lived experiences making conscious
efforts to respect people's pronouns and
challenging homophobic or transphobic
remarks even when we aren't in the room
these are basic principles of allyship
that can and should be applied to all
other marginalized communities by
substituting terms like gay with
disabled or transgender with immigrant
replacing queer with houseless or lgbtq
with bipo you can affect ly support and
advocate for various communities in this
way these are principles that involve
recognizing and supporting individuals
differences and assisting them in
navigating an unequal worlds where they
may lack adequate support or protection
as the late great Mara P johnon said no
Pride for some of us without Liberation
for all of
us as we all may be noticed our
constituents who are part of or
supportive to the lgbtq community have
been keeping an eye on the decisions
made made in this room regarding their
civil rights as a member of this
community I want to extend our thanks
for the years of hard work from
individuals on both sides of the aisle
who have strived for decades to make our
state a welcoming and fair place for all
thank you all for your good work and I
hope to see her again next year
[Applause]
chair recognize representative
Shu
yes thank you Mr Speaker and thanks to
those of you who are still here I Rise
remind us all that tomorrow is Flag Day
and I present for you an adaptation of a
poem by John J Daly from the era of
World War I it's called a toast to the
flag here's to the red of it there's not
a thread of it no nor a shred of it in
all the spread of it from foot to head
but Heroes bled for it Precious Blood
shed for it bathing it
red here's to the white of it thrilled
by the sight of it who knows the right
of it but has felt the might of it
through day and night Womanhood care for
it made manhood Dare for it purity's
prayer for it kept it so
white here's to the blue of it Heavenly
View of it Star Spangled Hue of it
honesty's do of it constant and
true diadems gleam from it states stand
Supreme for it Liberty beams from it
brightens the
blue here's to the ho of it stars
stripes and pole of it hears to the soul
of it red white and blue thank you
[Applause]
for what reason member rise I moved that
the remarks on Flag Day and on Pride uh
be printed in the permanent journal
without objection representative Au move
that the house standing recess for the
purpose of receiving messages and Ro
Bill amendments rooll Bill reports at
the completion of which the house will
stand adjourn to the call of the chair
are ready for the question all those fav
say I those n eyes have it and the house
stands and re the call of the chair